right good evening for crate tonight
some like to see there's a Coventry City
fan I'm not used to big crowds so please
bear with me
my name's Andy Crump I will be chairing
tonight's planning committee meeting
will be exciting each planet application
on its merits can I crave your
indulgence and ask you to turn your
mobile phones off or turn them off
designed and I'll do mine at the same
time because there's nothing worse than
somebody speaking and being interrupted
by understands of the Great Escape or or
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse or whatever so if
we could turn them off please or and
also could I ask any the registered
speakers speak without any interruptions
however tempting it might be please do
not interrupt because if it comes to but
I'll have to clear the room and I've
never done that in my time is playing
chair but it's always the first time and
I don't want it to be tonight
so if you could just bear with us thank
you very much just like to introduce the
top table Karen Tate I'm the team leader
planners East in my role as an impartial
adviser to the committee I can clarify
any planning issues that arise doing so
I'm bound by the code of Professional
Conduct of the Royal Town Planning
Institute planning committee members are
not bound by the case officers
recommendation or by oral advice thank
you Ruby's Kuhlman Senior Planner Louise
Casey planner Joseph Brooke Planet yeah
item two sorry apologies for absence
thank you capsule names dispositive
interest okay sorry good evening chair
with regard to application 18 4/3 3 6 1
6 4 - full
at a site meeting on Monday and also I'm
I'm known to the wife of the objector on
application 19 forward slash zero zero
one thirty nine as received a phone call
I advised the caller that I was unable
to just discuss any aspect of the
planning application and the call then
finished as far as I'm concerned and
this is before I'd actually seen the
papers I'm there for coming to the
meeting this evening with an open mind
on as Ward man but I will be speaking on
two applications this evening eighteen
for zero two three seven eight forward
slash very and also one nine four slash
zero zero one three nine four slash ful
[Music]
thanks mister chairman so I went to the
site visit during the week on an
application and for the first
application that to receive
correspondence we all have
and any other site visit the matzoh brei
you call me Barnes again board member
for item number 218 / / three six one
six four and I shall be speaking on that
application
ketchup a German I was on the original
site visit of when the first application
came to committee but that several years
ago I think that's the one Peter Barnes
is referring councilor Barnes is
referring to but it was it was prior to
when it first came yeah I'm familiar
with the site and the other site visit
Schuster has been mentioned was the
Meiji barn and any other members wish to
declare in test all was was that yep
thank you very much I need to make a
slight adjustment with that with your
approval and I like to bring application
number six which is 1900 1 5 9 / ferry
forward on the agenda and the reasons
will become apparent shortly if Joe
would you like to come and do that one
there sorry Louise
since it says there's no yep
thank you sure the reason the
applications requested or even brought
forward is originally it was brought
forward to committee on the request of
the Paris Council which were objecting
to the condition a number five the
original application in 2015 to being
amended from the original pre
commencement start date due to my
recommendation the very word in which is
prior to the pouring of concrete the
Parish Council have withdrawn our
objection and therefore it we I believe
it should be delegated decision check
something else could you come forward to
the table as warden and the police
I just like to ask you a question are
you happy to agree the bow no more than
happy mr. Chen thank you very much
I have nothing to say on that I'm pretty
good so just that get approval from
committee to delegate the supplication
all those in favor the bonds all those
in favor
yes the saint are you voting on this one
okay so I'm not against any against and
one abstention
Thank You committee resolves to delegate
the decision to officers on this
application
thank you Thank You Jen Thank You
council knows right well revert back to
our running order and the next
application is 18 / 0 - 37 might vary
the rod broke postures Preston monster
stratford-on-avon
Turner farm and associated development
without complying with conditions - and
for our planning permission a PP /j 372
0 / w / 16/3 1 6 4 7 1 1 and are
presented officer is Louise Thank You
chair the application site is located on
39.7 hectares of agricultural land which
is situated approximately one kilometer
north east of lower Quinton village and
1.9 kilometers south of Preston on star
village this site is identified by the
red line on the map and comprises of
nine small to medium sized fields and
lies approximately 1.2 kilometers from
the Cotswolds
a.m.
identified by the yellow line on the map
here the scheduled ancient monument me
on hill fort lies 2.4 kilometers from
the site which also lies within the a
cots or 0mb
and also 1.2 kilometers from a scheduled
ancient monument to the southeast at
Bruton farm the site is not located in
the conservation area and the nearest
listed building is rapid manner which
lies approximately 400 meters there we
go
northwest of the site a gas pipeline
also runs through the northern part of
the site and Preston bushes a woodland
adjoins part of the southern boundary of
the site whilst there's no public
footpaths that run through the site
itself there are a number within close
proximity there is a footpath
approximately 100 meters to the east on
the opposite side of AK Newton Road at
Merton Lane apologies and a bridle way
runs approximately 200 to 300 meters to
the north and west further afield there
is also a number of public footpaths
within the Cotswolds a omv a particular
note is the footpath which traverses the
northeastern slope with me and Hill and
is part of the way marked monarchs way
and centenary way this application is
seeking to very condition to and form
attached to the Planning Commission a
double p4 slash through at J 372 Oh
/w for such 16 or such three one six
four seven one one granted on appeal for
the construction of a solar farm for a
25 year period
condition 2 of the permission relates to
the timescale of the permission and the
applicant is seeking to extend this from
25 years to 40 years condition for
relates to the
approved plans which is sought to be
amended through the introduction of a
number of changes which I will expand
upon momentarily firstly what I'm
showing you at the moment is the
approved layout the key element to be
noting are the location of the
substation which is in this location
here the arrangement of the access
tracks these are the internal access
tracks there is one main and trent's
which is coming from the admin turn lane
and so there's access trucks here along
here there's also some that go into the
field from from this position along here
and that there's there's ones that go
down on the certain field in addition
there's the position of the inverters
which are located these are thought
black rectangles here and also there's
new planting that's also included within
their periphery of the site on internals
but our particular note is the hedgerow
new hydro which is proposed along the
easternmost part of the solar panels
which are closest to the admin turn lane
in addition there's the temporary
construction compound which is located
in this field here this is the views
zoomed in slightly here see better
appreciation of everything this is the
gas pipeline here so this is the exhaust
existing access so what I'm showing you
now is the proposed layout firstly there
is the creation of a new contemporary
construction access which is in this
position here this is using an existing
field opening and it's proposed to have
the temporary construction compound
immediately adjacent
into it it will note that the levels of
the Landers are higher in this area
however immediately abuts badminton lane
the there is the the internal access
arrangements are proposed to be revised
basically reducing the length of tracks
and also reducing the their alignment so
in this area here we previously had an
access going in here with an inverter
going up here going around into this
area here so it has been reduced good to
some degree and also the number of and
position of the inverted inverted
happens has been reduced from 14 as
approved going down to 7 has now
proposed so previously we had
anniversary this field here also up here
there's a obviously a variety but there
there some of the key ones that have
gone a variety of amendments there the
security fencing alignment has also been
revised to take into account route
protection areas of existing trees and
hedgerows and also there's some slight
adjustments to the panel layout in
configuration also to take into account
the route protection areas and then
there is also an alteration to the
position of this substation so you can
see where the area identified in blue
that's flood zone 3 so it's proposed to
alter the location of the substation
from field B effectively in this area
here in 275 meters south east into field
C which is an flood zone one
zooming in its proposed to amend the
design of their substation buildings and
locate them next to each other
previously the substation buildings were
apart from one another so we are placing
the buildings next to one another
here we go zoomed in again and the
overall area of the buildings will
increase slightly by 16.7 square meters
but the overall height of the buildings
will be reducing from and approved
maximum height of five point three
meters going down to a maximum height of
three point nine meters and officers
consider that the overall impact will be
similar this is a layout of the approved
substation the internal arrangement
within the substation is very similar
the key difference is here's an
elevation so you've got the proved
substation compound and proposed
underneath the equipment is slightly
different but only marginally and the
key element to note is that the
disconnect er areas here of the poles
define the most they are increasing by
30 centimeters in purpose in the
proposed layout from 5.5 as approved
going up to 5.8 is proposed as a result
of all these changes the overall number
of panels is proposed to be reduced from
seventy four thousand and ninety three
so apologies from the approved seventy
four thousand and ninety three and it
should be reduced by eleven thousand
three hundred and seventeen panels so
that equates to the new sixty two
thousand seven hundred and seventy
panels
this would produce a peak output of 23.3
megawatts per year and that's equivalent
to approximately six thousand five
hundred and twenty five homes per year
now turning to the photographs these two
photographs have been supplied as part
of the LV ia assessment but they do give
a more of panoramic view of the of the
site so this is where the temporary
construction access would be proposed
together with the access track along
here and the construction compound the
hedge line this was taken approximately
in 2014 you'll see in a moment that the
hedgerow has increased in height along
this area here so this is again taken
the bottom photograph from Edmonton Lane
slightly further towards Preston
passages you can see here so this is the
field where the construction compound is
approved to be located in this area here
so solar panels are approved in this
field along here this is the first field
and now the approved set location of
this substation is approximately behind
these two trees these are good markers
for you to look at so behind there and
it's being moved further forward into
this field identified as field B so this
was taken as you can see yes two days
ago so this is the existing vehicle
access into into the site consider
topography of the land so this the is
sloping down into more of a plateau area
here so the solar panels are permitted
to be located and the bottom bit of the
field temporary access structure and
compound here and then just to give you
context these are the two trees where
the substation is approved to go behind
and it's effectively moving it
into this area here now these are vistas
showing the visibility's plays this is
towards Preston bushes woodland looking
a southerly direction this is looking in
a northerly direction towards Preston
pastures this is a looking in a
southerly direction so Preston bushes
woodland here now this is taken
immediately where the construction
compound would be proposed so I've tried
to have identified the fields for you so
this is the first field here this is
where the substation would be revised
revised position approved behind so
within all of these fields solar panels
have been approved to be allocated and
proposed to be sited and again in these
areas this is a view which I've taken
what which has been taken as it say from
the LV ia but this is from Radford Lane
a south of the site and this one is
taken from the public footpath to the
west of the site looking east and
identifying that he filtered views of
the solar panels may potentially be
obtained again from here finally this is
a view taken from me on Hill and again
this is the application sites within the
area here press them bushes here in
lower Quintin just to get context and
then I just would like to
videos not on there so there is
apologies there are six updates to
report which are detailed on the update
sheet and chairman the recommendation is
to grant Planning Commission a subject
to the conditions and notes as detailed
in the report okay
Thank You Louise club our first speaker
please which is Chancellor is he second
you've got three minutes which like a
warning with about 30 seconds to go that
would be thank you to from here me I
speak on behalf of the local community
and objecting to these proposals our key
concerns relate to the scope of the
proposed change as changes in the
supporting technical content and the
procedure by which the applicant has
sought to authorize these amendments the
scope of the changes include a 15 year
extension of the scheme's duration and
the relocation of the substation
construct and construction compound the
introduction of new yorkers tracks and
the lot of important screening measures
in all the proposals amount to a
substantial change I suggest to the
consent that was previously granted upon
appeal it is fair to conclude that these
changes particularly the 15-year
extension represent a fundamental
alteration and should not be determined
through a section 73 application process
instead I would suggest the proposal
suitably should be assessed through a
full planning application in order that
your committee can apply proper scrutiny
to a revised scheme and its supporting
technical information fundamentally the
proposed changes significantly allows
slow creep towards an unacceptable form
of development that is unlikely to have
been approved should it have been
considered at the time through the
original plan in the process and as such
the application would circumvent the
appropriate planning process and cannot
be used to authorize a lawful consent of
the previous proposal this situation is
compared confirmed through legal mode
that has been submitted by glassed
regard to the changes themselves the
operation extension to 40 years is
most concerning aspect of the proposals
an additional period of 15 years is
highly significant and arguably is not a
temporary application as suggested
originally this renders temporary become
permanent and this should require a
robust assessment of the Associated
planning balance to balance between
mitigating what gain there might be
around electricity as the long-term and
now even longer-term impact to a rule I
would suggest indeed it is noted that
the benefits of the proposal during this
additional time frame are expected to
wane as the panel's degrade over that
period of time and we've been giving
some update figures but I suggest those
don't give with true deprivation 15
seconds and in essence I would ask the
committee to agree with the legal
opinion that the music that the
community have thought that this would
not be a lawful application and should
be put aside pending a full planning
application thank you thank you very
much right okay so second before you go
any questions for the Kessler power
thank you good evening counselor second
I just wonder whether you in in in the
advice and the research whether you can
confirm whether there are any other
solar farms in the district or in
Warwickshire appreciate you're also the
leader of Warwickshire County Council
that have a permission with a 40 year
life span
[Music]
I haven't thought that information but
I'm not aware of any we can also us the
we can ask the agent can also ask the
officers as well and points of
clarification so hopefully we'll get the
answers on from one of us anyway so any
further questions cancer the second no
wait okay thank you
we move on to our next speaker which is
mr. James
Jemison James I'm sure Jamison Jamison
good man sorry about that
either way you've got three minutes and
again would you like a warning with
about 30 seconds thank you good evening
committee thanks for the opportunity to
present this application should wear
much has been said about the sauron
especially by those against its
development the professional hiring
objectors and their professional legal
advisers however as noted in the case
officers reports there's no need to go
over all this detail again the principle
is established and it's not up for
discussion
nor are the majority of the issues which
have been raised and I'll focus on
clarifications and summarized issues as
evening as clearly out changes will
result in reduced or similar impacts our
stance actually accepted by the
objectors legal adviser a clarification
from the counsel's comments earlier and
nonetheless it should be noted that the
the objectors maintain the review that
they're the material in an appropriate
that haven't presented any evidence to
support these views and they're not
balanced against the benefits of the
proposals which is keep on the other
hand an independent review of the
landscape visual impact assessment
concluded there were no material changes
as a result of any of the amendments
there's no attempt to sidestep the
condition discharge process as alleged
also be caught the conditions would be
copied over to a new consent and for
example in terms of the approved
external lighting which means some
issues the current consent covers flood
lighting and ex
clarification was simply added on the
plans are the public's requests when you
go energy and so on particular have
never been more popular as indicated by
wave 25 of the government's public
attitudes tracker which is available
online the public made it clear they
wanted to see solar farms stand up on
their own two feet without subsidies and
the fact of the matter is that time
Extension applications such as this are
been approved up and in the country for
subsidy fee solar farms as well as
public perception on demands this is in
line with the government's clean growth
strategy industrial strategy and the
council's local plan they all then
substantial support to subsidy for solar
farms then products will not be
materially different there's no evidence
presented to suggest that this will be
the case and application complies with
policy and guidance as the case officer
pointed out the proposed changes are
main material at most and will power
approximately six and a half thousand
homes each year and see if around four
hundred thousand tons of co2 over the 40
years they're also economic
opportunities and biodiversity
enhancements hey I'm conscious that some
information has been submitted to the
councils which we haven't seen in terms
of panel degradation and the MPF MPPs
supports even smaller scale renewable
energy generation schemes and attributes
them substantial weight so even with a
better degredation over a year over the
years they'll still generate a
substantial amount of power and should
be afforded substantial wait time after
time this project has been scrutinized
by impartial professionals for or
possibly five of your own case officers
including this evening's presentation
which I'm sure you'd agree with
comprehensive
numerous consul teas an independent
inspector and even a High Court judge
they're all satisfied that the benefits
of the scheme outweigh its impacts and
the correct legal processes have been
followed overall it changes our Manor
material and nature the application
complies with planning policy and
guidance
consent should be granted without delay
and line with the MPP F and the
development plan
thank you
and cancel yeah mr. Jamison I thought
it'd start of your presentation you were
trying to instruct the committee to take
notice of something and not other things
and I can assure you we are quite
capable of understanding the boundaries
of the decisions that we are about to
make now you say there's no material
difference but you want condition for
removed and in the report that we have
in front of us
condition for relates to something like
a dozen different drawings because
Society it was it's not removed its
amended condition for I think it says
well perhaps I'll clarify this then okay
thank you but but to me what the point
behind my question is I'm thinking if
there's a substantial amount of change
to these diagrams then I'm inclined to
agree with mrs. seccomb and think that a
fresh application is probably needed so
why do you therefore turn round and say
oh just approve it it's been happening
up and down the country what evidence
might you have of that yeah I don't
quite understand the question sorry
yeah I think counts the Saint was asking
what evidence is about because it's
potentially a significant change and
conditions for two and four what
evidence have you got from around the
country that come back up this change
that makes it appropriate etc I think
that's right well I don't need to point
to the applications Jochen has one
merits but and we're set to and detail
on the application why we believe the
changes are minor material at most
including the extension from 25 to 40
years the layout changes are very minor
in nature and then I gots been explained
in detail in the application hunt and
this woman's presentation and in terms
of the tame extension application I
personally have obtained four or five of
these in the last year or so and in
other parts of the country they might
not have been a you know applied foreign
Warwickshire or nearby but they have
been approved elsewhere but each
application sturgeon is one minute so
again now I have another question
related to the alleged minor amendments
in her presentation
Louise refer to the height of buildings
I think starting of five point three
meters and dropping to three point
something or other thank you right
can you mr. Jamison explain to the
members just what proportion of
buildings will be five meters high and
what might only be three point eight
meters high questions clear sundae's
Thanks none of the buildings will be
five point three meters high they've all
been reduced in height that were the the
current Planning Commission consents
buildings up to five point three meters
high we are proposing to reduce the
height to a max on a three point nine so
there's an overall reduction in height
off the buildings on the site yeah in
terms of the overall heights what mr.
Jamison is saying is correct
the there is one of the buildings and
certain part is three point five so five
point three meters in height the maximum
height of the proposed buildings is
three point nine so okay sorry 3.9 3.9
is the maximum height of the of the
proposed buildings so there is a height
reduction as a result of this
development and in terms of the the 30
centimeters that's in relation to to the
transformer poles within the substation
compound itself it's not the the
approved plan already allows them to be
five point five meters and it's the 30
centimeter increase which would be
resulting as a part of this proposal
okay thank you thank movies for that
explanation I clearly misunderstood what
she was telling us before there is one
other point Louise did say that the
number of inverters to be employed was
going to reduce now perhaps I'll explain
for those that don't know it I am a
chartered engineer and I understand all
about inverters and things from my
professional work and it strikes me if
there's going to be a substantial
reduction mr. Jensen that you might be
reducing the total output of the solar
farm itself is this correct
no so they're more highly rated each one
that's great to you when we applied for
planning consent I think we included
maybe 12 or 15 1 megawatt rated
inverters and the clients are the
applicant now intends to deploy inverter
ISM the region of two and a half three
megawatts each I'm a planner not an
electrical engineer light yourself but
the rating of the inverter has increased
since we applied and they can thankfully
deploy less
more buildings on the site which we see
as a a benefit cancer peri Thank You
chair good evening miss Jameson the loss
of agricultural land for an additional
15 years obviously is a major concern
particularly when at the last but the
first time this application came forward
I can remember the applicant clearly
emphasizing the importance that the land
would be turned over to agricultural use
again after 25 years on the basis that
66% of agricultural land if we only can
access 66% of agricultural land in the
UK for food provision
I just welcome your views on the
extending the 15 years and the impact
it's going to have on agricultural land
produce in addition I'd also like to
question you
you mentioned the project has been
scrutinized by professionals from the
outset can you explain why you didn't go
for 40 years in the first application so
in the first cultural landfill it's
important to note that there's no loss
of agricultural land because the scheme
has been designed to been able to be
grazed by sheep throughout its
generation that's a legal requirement
between us as applicant and the
landowner they won't enter into at least
where they've been able to grow a sheep
on it and and that will be the case over
the longer duration of this operation
and the plank system can't insist cannot
insist that the land is greased but the
scheme is clearly designed to enable
grazing and that's the intention
throat's throughout the 40 years of
operation so him there's no loss of
agricultural land as the dual use we've
saw a farm solar panels with sheep
grazing and then around the panel so
that's as a key distinction between
joyous and loss and on your second
question sorry which was about
basically you've mentioned how the
project has been totally scrutinized by
professionals I'd like to know why from
the outset didn't put a planning
application in for 40 years and it went
for 25 Thanks and when the solar
industry or when the renewable energy
industry started in a kind of meaningful
commercial scale there were two forms of
subsidy available feed-in tariffs or the
Renewable obligation certificate for for
solar and the Renewable obligation
certificate run for twenty years and I
think the feed-in tariff was either 20
or 25 so at that time agreements were
drawn up with landowners and planning
applications put in for applications
which should be consent for 25 years
obviously things have changed since then
there's been a removal of the subsidy
which has a noted was a key policy
promise from the current government and
members of the public working to see the
new energy schemes stand up without the
subsidy so the increased time scale
helps with that and but the original
time scale and as I would point out that
most wind farms offshore onshore wind
farms all farms they were all applied
for on the basis of 25 years there was
an energy norm so you know we applied
for planning consent for this in 2014 I
think and the legal agreements with
landowner etcetera and the project plans
we would have been put together and the
the one or two years preceding that so
quite some time ago when everything was
based in 25 years the bonds and the
perimeter first on the most concerned
about like you said you've changed yeah
so for clarity there's no lighting
proposed in the state other than to
flood lake homes within the substation
area there's no there's no lighting
around there but amateur events for
example there's no lighting on the CCTV
cameras and in the periphery and the
lighting within the substation compound
was approved by the original planning
application and
just been shown and amended plans which
have cemented first planning application
for continuity
I think some members of the public
packed up in essence thought we were
trying to sneak in floodlights not the
case the fallen part of the approved
plans and there is a condition requiring
the final detail of the flood lighting
to agree before it can be installed and
and the case office and I also discussed
the potential for a condition
restricting the flood Lighting's used to
emergency use and maintenance essential
maintenance which would be happy to
agree to as well and is manually
operated it's not motion activated when
there was a subsidy in place we proposed
community benefit fund that is being
honored and in principle and spirit by
the new owners of the solar former
clients but they can't instead of
offering a monetary sum per year based
on the skill of the the solar form there
have been some discussions with the
parents Kim Soo about giving
contribution to the rule out of local
broadband and so I mean personally
parted to those discussions and our
colleagues been undertaking them for you
know just to keep the two channels clear
and but you know the husband advanced
there are advanced discussions with the
parish council about making a monetary
contribution to head their self-funded
broadband rollout so nothing's been
confirmed yet on the community
contribution nothing formally confirmed
as far as more weird butts and the
discussions are advanced and being
honest I think it would take the parish
were the greatest well you know
something to finalize plans and gain
funding
but the money has been set aside for
that intercourse questions than the
panels how obviously things have moved
on since they first came out how a
viable ally over a 40-year period likes
to expect to last that long will I be
revised what's the replacement rights
outside give me some more details about
those please of course and the reason
for applying for 40 years is that they
the manufactures provide a 40 year
warranty and so the were confident that
I'll provide you know solid oak over
that 40-year period
they do degrade over time and and the
might be have you taken at some point
about like repowering would inform to
the police panels or sections of panels
or upgrade inverters and if that
decision was taken whenever we know 20
30 years whenever that might be closer
there's a discussion with the planning
authority about whether or not that's a
material change you know how that
process will be undertaken to my mind if
there's a like-for-like replacement then
there's there's no material impact and
the yes so to answer your question I
guess the the lifespan is longer than it
used to be they don't agree it is
quickly here the industry is more mature
now and there's more available
information on the the degradation
skills in the processes and they aren't
degrading as quickly as as it was
initially anticipated so obviously
you're seeking permission of up to 40
years is that correct
or 40 years 40 years it's what with the
platform yeah one policy and the
conditions are that when you leave the
site it has to be put back in the
condition you found it or something
similar that's correct yeah as I said
the the conditions which are attached to
the fuel decision we're happy with the
99 percent of them we can walk around
manor shoes etc and they will be applied
if that but if there's applications
approved those conditions would be
applied to the new consent a key
condition of that is that the end of the
solar farms operation or if
if it doesn't produce power for I think
it's 12 months in either of those cases
the everything would be removed from the
state and be restored to its current
condition essentially attacked pure
agricultural production over the first
10 years and 90% at 25 years it doesn't
say anything about 40 years your current
place yeah as a rule of thumb when the
agreement industry was started or when
it kicked off there was a 1% per year
degradation rate used which ties in with
certainly the first 10 years of that the
comment you've made and that degradation
the reads we understand is lower a
conservative estimate was used him and
it depends when that information was
produced and what tapers all Apollo it
relates to what size had when the
manufacturer was and the various aspects
of the manufacturing process and the
actual tape of panel which needs to be
to clarify if I'll late for like a
comparison and my review is that the
panel's even after 40 years around the
40 years will continue to or still be
producing a substantial amount of power
which should outweigh the impacts of the
scheme mr. Jameson I think you're free
to go now very much and clever next week
which is catch slow Donald there's the
ward member
and you've got five minutes can't slow
down
I'm good evening committee I just like
to clarify a point that was raised by
mr. Jameson the government has not asked
people to stand on their own two feet
with regards to solar farm applications
they actively discouraging certif armed
applications on agricultural land I have
a letter from the Dean zaharie who said
I'm solar power should play a central
role in our transition to a low-carbon
economy I am concerned however that the
loss of agricultural land two solar
arrays damages the element of the
environment English farm land is some of
the best in the wild and should be
dedicated to growing quality food and
crops I therefore welcome the fact that
government discourages landowners from
constructing solar farms on the best and
most versatile agricultural land and as
of 2015 has withdrawn farm subsidies
from land occupied by solar farms given
the complexity of this case the extent
of public opposition I feel that it's
vital that this application comes before
committee I would ask you to reflect on
the scrutiny aspect of your all tonight
as you also consider the meaning of
minor and temporary
we've already had six updates this
evening along with the following changes
to the original application the
relocation of the substation and
construction compound onto a higher
ground so even with the height
restriction it's going to be more
noticeable because of the higher
elevation and the lighting is above that
the introduction of new access tracks
the inverter cabins being sited on
higher ground the inclusion of lighting
columns and lots of important screening
measures the 15-year extension of the
scheme's duration the ladies and
gentlemen this is a new application in
combination these changes amount to a
substantial change to the consent that
was previously granted at Appeal these
changes particularly the 15 year
extension represent a fundamental
alteration to the existing permission
the section 73 application process can
be used to seek minor material
amendments to a consented development
proposal but legal opinion as referenced
by councillor circum from foot Anstey at
the request of grasped strongly advises
the cumulative impact of all of the
above changes goes way beyond a section
73 and that considers been minor
material and I would ask has a council
sought legal advice to see if this
application meets the test to pass
section 73 if it hasn't is it worth
deferring until it
a 40 year 40 years the timescale of a
generation could this extended 40-year
timeline really have been in the
inspectors mindset when he granted
permission to the original 25 years the
proposed changes represent a shift
towards an unacceptable form of
development that you would not have
passed through at the initial planning
process in respect of the proposed
changes to the operational extension to
40 years it is without doubt the most
concerning aspect of the application as
such an extension requires a
comprehensive reassessment at the
proposal the green renewable benefit of
these proposal wanes over time as the
efficiency of the panel degrades I'm not
sure mr. Jameson gets his facts but no
solar panel has a 40 year warranty and
the inverters have a warranty of 20
years now they don't degrade completely
after 25 years but that digression rate
is important because no mechanism has
been proposed in order to monitor the
situation or to ensure that the panels
will be replaced
we need detailed information regarding
make type lifespan plus degradation rate
of the solar panels proposed before you
as a committee can make a thorough
judgment whilst the applicant deserts
the panels would be easily replaced it's
really unlikely that would be
economically viable to complete a
wholesale replacement of 62,000 panels
if the consent is only authorized for
remaining 10 or 15 years the panel
degradation will result in a less
renewable form of development than that
on the original application and this
impacts upon the planning balance and
environmental impact such as the
prolonged loss of good agricultural land
which is a concern noted by Nadine
earlier on and can I ask well they'd
really be sheep grazing under the solar
panels you'll fit far less sheep on with
the solar panels there to my knowledge
I'm not aware of any other solar farms
in our district they have sheep grazing
below the panel's so if any of you are
I'm interested to know therefore the
loss of farmland is long-term ie 40
years the applicant argues that his land
is not a good agricultural quality but
evidence is imprecise and an expert
review of the applicant submission found
that the applicants assessment was and I
quote not have adequate quality or
detail to provide any tangible evidence
as the quality of the agricultural land
they inspected previously
for us dissatisfaction with the land
grading issues when determining the
appeal but that was when he specifically
noted a lack of alternative evidence and
the significance of the temporary
timescale of 25 years now our cs5 states
the proposal should protect landscape
character and avoid detrimental effects
the inspector noted as referenced in the
committee report that the report that
the proposal for 25 years scheme would
result in a mark changed the character
and appearance of the site and erode its
unspoiled open qualities and have a high
magnitude of change and major adverse
effects the officer except that by
extending the life of the development by
15 years the duration of these major
adverse impacts will be extended this is
a serious concern it is clear this
application is flawed
more information is needed and surely a
new application is required people think
any questions I did I've got the same
letter from I think the be quiet it was
discourages landowners from constructing
so the farms on the best and most
versatile agricultural land do you know
what grade this land was and is it the
best and most versatile land for
agriculture the evidence has been
inconsistent ideally I think it has to
be 3b or above but I just have to double
check that they claimed that the
evidence was not consistent and as
nobody can get access to the land apart
from the applicant we only can take his
word on it but the evidence supplied
regarding the quality of the land was
not considered adequate when it was
assessed by independent experts on that
but no one had access to the land so we
can't verify it
I've been told that during the the
inspector was happy with the information
provided about the London so so I've
just been advised so again like that
comment can I just come back to you on
that though that was with regards as he
was expressed his satisfaction with the
land grading issues in doing so he
specifically noted the lack of
alternative evidence and the
significance of the temporary timescale
of twenty five years so this extra 15
years puts a whole load of pressure on
that land okay catch the balance and
calcify I was just wondering whether you
had any information on what the land had
been used in the past for was it just
for grazing sheep or was it for crops as
well it's my understanding it's on a
crop rotation so you wouldn't keep the
same activity on the land
it goes on rotation and crops and then
grazing so there is there is a loss of
agricultural land because you couldn't
grow crops under solar panels could you
it'd be very difficult to harvest them
Council yeah I think we will raise the
officer for clarification as well I have
got one point I well need to make that I
believe cancel a Donnell you queried the
validity of the statement about a 40
year warranty on the panels which mr.
Jameson mentioned is that right
I did haven't done extensive research
talking to solar power providers today
yes yep so what I will do is obviously
you've questioned that I will ask for a
further comment to where you can clarify
what you've got that information from
warranties just to make sure we are
clear and throw on this which is I also
mentioned that you do is that as a
committee need to know the make and
degradation rate etc before you can make
a judgement so you need some really
specific information that should have
been included with auntie
to be fair right any further questions
thank you can't slow down
it's mr. Jamison still here could you
come forward again please we just need
to clarify the point about the forty
year warranty on so the panels and just
that one please nothing else yeah yep
the fund that we work whether the
applicant is one of the main solar
energy funds in the UK and they have
informed us that the the financial
mechanisms which they buy the panel's
through stand-up over the forty years
now maybe that's not explicitly a
warranty maybe as a replacement program
I don't know I'm not party to those
discussions and I sort of think being
blunt is material consideration and I
also think it would be over baiting of
the planning authority to insist on the
specific size and manufacturer
manufacturer and the type of solar
panels for for the solar farm I think
I've been unreasonable level of detail
okay thank you
right we'll move on to points of
clarification fee officer catch the
barns and counselor saintly well
clarification of the land as far as I
know that's got a Brook going through it
I think it's 3 / 3 / 3 1 & 2 is good
land 3 & 4 he's not you've got the
actual figure yeah the inspectors
comments I think that's the inspector
assess the land in terms of the evidence
that was supplied before him and he was
happy with the conclusion that there is
a mix of grade 3b and four within the
details of my committee report
identified that majority the fields a 3b
with two being through being four and
those are identified in there and also
the inspector did state that he
understood the intention was to let
sheep graze and a part of the site
during the duration of the operational
phase of the development so and and also
it would be it would not involve the
loss of best and most versatile
agricultural land and would be for a
temporary period reversible and we
support the viability of local
agricultural business and there will be
no significant effect on the
agricultural industry I'm quoting from
the inspectors decision the planning
game as I said on - we've had five or
six over the time you didn't seem to
know whether there was a planning game a
local gain or whether there wasn't there
was broadband the worthiest of the was
that is there or written there but I'm
saying he's and that 200 acres up the
road a dog well we did negotiate for the
hospital to have solar panels they also
give school
money to schools in a big area the one
that was it kind to not teach it in a
whatever by the railway that did a lot
of work for the school I'm just
wondering as you seen an isolated spot
is there any planning game or has it or
hasn't it not been agreed counsel answer
we haven't got the information present I
would in my view assess this application
without that information transfers site
yes chairman to this business of forty
years and quality of land now on page
two there is a list of other material
considerations other documents
stratford-on-avon renewable energy
landscape sensitivity study 2014 I would
have thought and I say that because I
was the portfolio holder the saw this
thing through into adoption in 2014 as
well as leader of the council and
effectively was managing the process the
question becomes there's probably far
more reliable information in that about
the quality of the land than there is in
the inspectors report who clearly had
doubts because of the evidence that was
or wasn't presented so can we have a
quote please from the landscape
sensitivity study about the quality of
this land through check we just need to
remind members that the issue of
agricultural land classification was
brought to to judicial review and was
assessed by the court and the
application was it was quashed
I think Mason may interject here for the
REC terminology here yes while the the
order is in front of me chair and
basically the applicants didn't get
permission by the court to actually take
it further
so the court refused him permission for
leaved to apply to the court for
judicial review well that still doesn't
answer my question what does the
landscape sensitivity studies say about
the deviation to say that there was some
other assessment done by some other
legal eagle right I want to know what
our landscape
assessment and our landscape expert said
about the quality of this land in the
study that we adopted as a council that
is our policy guidance through you can I
refer you to the original appeals
decision on this planning policy and the
inspector very clearly has drawn on the
stratford-on-avon district renewable
energy landscape sensitivity study and
points out the peel site lies within the
Feldon Vale farmlands landscape
character type and the Aven Vale
farmlands lct is immediately to the west
the sensitivity of both El CTS to very
large solar farms about 25 hectares is
medium-high now he drew on that in
coming to his conclusion as to the
acceptability of this scheme and I would
remind you that you're dealing with an
application for a variation so the
principle is established for a solar
farm on this site all right Thank You
chair I would like to know from the
officers whether in fact there are any
other solar farms in the district that
have planning permission for a 40-year
life
actually members may recall that there
is the burden farm development that has
been permitted to be a 40 year period
here in Stratford can I also ask what
the percentage increase in the buildings
are that the amendments to the buildings
I know you mentioned as a square metre
äj--
could you just put that in percentage
terms for us
in terms of the buildings themselves
there's still two buildings as approved
there's two buildings effectively being
proposed the just I'll give you the
dimensions the buildings themselves
that's probably better
so the approved control room and meeting
meter buildings has a floor area of
twenty nine point six meters with a
maximum reach height of five point three
and then there's the separate comms
building with a floor area of twenty one
point six meters and a height of two
point four what is being proposed is
control and meter room building which
has a floor area of 23.5 so that's
slightly smaller in floor area than the
approved one because that was twenty
nine point six however this one has got
reduced Ridge heights of three point
five and here's a flat roof building
whereas the other one's a pitched roof
building now the switch room has a
larger floor area that's forty four
point four meters but it only has and it
has a height of 3.9 so as I said before
in my presentation there's a difference
in overall floor area of 16 point I
think sixteen point seven or square
meters but overall the massing of the
buildings is actually being reduced from
five point three to a maximum of three
point nine I think it's the best way of
analyzing it no counts the same yes
chairman sorry I forgot also in this
list of other material considerations on
page two it refers to the
some Department of Energy and Climate
Change documents 2013 2014 2013 so do i
presume that we're being presented with
the latest versions of those documents
and they haven't been updated as far as
we're all aware they're the same yeah so
they relate to the time when as mr.
Jameson said it was the norm to offer 25
years they relate to that period coolly
as applicable as mr. Jameson saying is
that we are seeing more applications
extending time periods that's longer
while extending time periods beyond that
40 years as we've already approved
previously within this district okay
Kansas yep yeah I've got a couple
questions Louise can Snowden all
mentioned the the current usage was crop
rotation and have you got the
information on that and can you give me
any details of where grazing is used on
any current sites of solar panels I can
inform you with the first part certainly
from my site visits and I believe when
the inspector assessed the site back in
2000 and I think was 16 the site was
grazed as far as I'm aware unfortunately
I haven't got the the landowner here to
say about crop rotation but certainly it
has been grazed for a considerable
period I'm not aware of arable
production on this land in terms of
other alternatives where sheep grazing
has occurred within the district
I'm afraid I'm just limited to the the
sites that I've personally dealt with
I believe there is a site in rant way
adjacent to the foss foss way there
which I approved there was a sheep
grazing was approved to be allowed
within that site as well it is
constructed now whether they are or not
I can't clarify thank you very much
right I think well move on to is about
them you catch the bonds and then cancel
apart just to clarify I suppose this ten
fifteen twenty five forty years when
this first started these panels they had
no idea how long they were going to last
and with modern technology that this way
it's gone the morning up the Ulster Road
which is that well not a hundred times
bigger than this but nearly that done
they've got an option because they don't
know how long the the panels that
they've bought now I think they came
from China
they've both the last 20 years so a lot
of these places now because we're we're
moving into a field that we don't really
understand have options for different at
times so that my eyes in the respect is
helpful in the respect of maybe more
we've got the forty years obviously if
you don't have to keep changing them
some of the ones that were built early
on have had to be changed already but
those of course will be substantially
longer as modern technology moves the
ones in Germany that they were producing
minute know intuitively they think they
might last a hundred years so we're in a
new ballgame I suppose you could say it
I went to the site visit nobody wants
the solar panel farm
next to them we went in the house that
was I think the closest my brain was
with this or she took a stand enjoy
remember when we went and saw busy the
worst obviously great concern the grade
of London is not good it's got a stream
running through it
seasoned in the floodplain but a lot of
livestock or actually use now because
the panels are substantial more
substantial than they used to be and
there's plenty of grazing underneath
them at the one bought the railroad but
go over towards console or bishops each
engine that has a lot of wildflowers
with the school so as far as I'm
concerned I appreciate them there is
concern they've been concerns all the
way through on this side and then that's
life where the sighted dog will wear 200
acres was contaminated land and has to
be used for something we were sort of
pushed into it and that was now which we
shareholders but as far as I'm concerned
I can't see any reason in the in the
land or the environmental assessment any
difference to what the inspector said
and overturned as you say I didn't know
bit of public inquiry as well so as far
as I'm concerned
unfortunately for the people here I've
got to go along with the officers
recommendation Thank You chairman
firstly I don't think we can compare for
40 years for Burton farm solar farm
which is basically on a landfill site
with open countryside you're talking
about
well it's a it is it is not about that
back in a minute put that past
paraffinic
that the reason what he was was they had
a lot of cat animals that were killed
and given disease that's why nothing to
do with it
okay I'm entitled to my point of view
and as far as I'm concerned we cannot be
comparing this particular site with
Burton farm solar also business business
is all about risk and reward
all of us who are in business the goal
posts often change but that doesn't mean
in terms of the tariffs and that the
monies that go back to the developer
that the villagers should have to bear
the brunt of an additional 15 years of
blighted countryside in my view they
already have what I call is a prison
sentence around them and by granting the
application equates to almost like a
death sentence because they won't see
that countryside again well they
wouldn't if if they're they're my age
anyway and the other side of the coin is
if you take the forty years and you put
the percentage increase on the twenty
five that is 60%
that isn't a sixty percent increase on
the impact on this countryside it's not
just fifteen years it's sixty percent so
as far as I'm concerned you put all
these factors together it amounts to a
completely new planning application you
can't tell me that sixty percent impact
additional impact is a slight variation
so as far as I'm concerned I cannot
support this application I think it
needs to be withdrawn and the if the
developer wants to go for forty years
he needs to start from ground one again
yep consistent Kingsman just one points
that seems to in councillor Perry speech
there is that the section 73 application
has been decided all being confirmed by
the council as a correct application
therefore the councillors just must look
at the two conditions that are being
assessed tonight so if you look at page
seven that sets out what you must
undertake can I just come back chairman
as far as I'm concerned the addition
it's the additional of the 15 years
because of the the visual impact of the
development because of the additional 15
years which represents an increase of
60% in terms of impact and also the
effect of the development on the
character of the neighborhood because
it's going to be there for an additional
15 years and just confirmed can that
should be done through condition 2 and
there should be no basically intrusion
into the actual application itself we've
accepted a sections section 73
applications so it's do the two
conditions that we should assess cancer
brain condition 2 for if you look at
condition for does a to K elements it's
not just one amendment it's several yes
but it depends on the material
amendments we've got some strong
language summer quite emotive language
and I'm sure I'm sure
I 237 I'm sure you'll be here in the
next 40 years cancer parent caps the
bonds no pence the mills are you
indicated next thanks mr. chairman yes I
could go along to look at the site and
it wasn't on the first hearing
in my opinion this is that just another
application by stealth
that's a I'm not sure whether this would
have been granted they've come forward
for when they came forward and said
forty years I'm not sure we're being
granted there is a of course there is a
loss of natural grazing land here but
that's not what we're here about we're
here about the age of fifteen years mr.
chairman I I cannot support the officers
recommendation on this it's subject in
the the people who live around this site
for another 15 years as councillor Perry
said it's a terrible thing so I just
cannot support this application mr.
chairman as there are so many amendments
here um I'm surprised that we're not
actually going for another application
or a fresh application but if that was
the case I would recommend it at Societe
exactly what Mesa says and look at these
two conditions he'll be pleased to know
that I'm volunteering to behave myself
right so consequently I said earlier
probably regret this that I was a
chartered engineer and effectively my
professional advice to anybody on this
would be that effectively you can't
guarantee stop having a life of 40 years
when 25 has been the norm it will
probably take some time into that period
for us to be able to make a realistic
assessment as to what the real life is
and anything that other than conjecture
is sorry only conjecture is the way of
looking at this so consequently I
disagree I would want to turn down the
quest to have the permission granted
expiring no later than 25 years now
that's condition for as councillor Mills
has just said in I mentioned earlier
there are a dozen or more variations to
the diagrams that were approved and
these are substantial we're told that
the inverters are going to be higher
rated we're gonna toll that the be LEED
buildings are going to shrink in size
we're told if you look at this that the
CTV TV system is going to change so
perhaps there's a question of security
modifications but we haven't asked any
questions about that
so I'll leave that out for the moment
and therefore we have a situation
whereby probably the location plans are
okay but everything else is subject to
some change and we're told by mr.
Jameson that the changes are
insignificant or can we treat them as
insignificant why can't I think quite
frankly they are substantial and
therefore now I'll give you an example
sorry I'm going to have to declare a
personal interest here as you know I had
a planning application coming in and I
wanted to move a float and Louise had
one of the Louise's knows all about this
and I did move the flow and I got
permission to move the flow but I had to
put in a separate planning application
to do so and I think this is what's
required here and that was quite a
simple application and therefore we have
a situation whereby if members of the
council are expected to put a revised
application in for moving a chimney or a
flue then I think if someone wants to
make this about a substantial changes
they should put in a fresh application
and not try and do it on an amendment
and I thought the application came in
your application in is because you'll
remember a planning committee rather
than a normal member of the public so
you had to reply so
so but I can I can understand your hairs
mr. chair I can understand your point
myself clear so consequently we have a
number of issues here a number of
changes now we're not told by which
these revised diagrams will apply we've
been given some information about the
building's being less height and greater
areas and we're given some changes but
effectively I think they are substantial
enough you know substantially enough to
actually warrant a new application and
therefore we should refuse this
application this evening because that
will be a pathway to making certain that
the applicant puts a proper application
in so that we can look at it not by
comparison with what's been approved
although that will be a material
consideration but by a proper assessment
of what is then put forward right
just to reiterate all you said that the
District Council has accepted the
section 73 application it's the two
conditions in front to you that you need
to assess and come up with reasons for
right so we found three speakers so far
against an application one for it I'll
be only another cancer Brian just
picking up on what mater said that the
council has accepted to section 73 is it
not for this committee to accept it as
well that's the first question
I'll come back to chair the other point
I would like to make is some of this
applications before us on a new
technology the solar panels or ever you
want to call them while reading the
report somewhere the panel's will read
to be replaced as technology improves or
advances so we still have the same
technology in 40 years I think not so
there is a chance that these panels will
be changed quite regularly I would think
as technology comes on board but don't
have anybody can answer that question
I think in terms of replacement of that
panels may well fail during the life of
the application they may well be
replaced or they may just stay in situ
and this to have a lower output from the
site itself but technology isn't
inevitably going to advance but
obviously the the impact of the
development is before you which to
assess I believe not that members could
not alter it because the council has
accepted the application by way of its
officers who have the expertise and have
assessed the application serve accepted
it so also it puts us in position if we
were to say that a new application would
be considerably going against the
process that we've accepted and
therefore we could be subject to further
court action from the applicants
therefore I'm suggesting that the
members should assess the application in
front of them and not the consideration
of a full application confident
without reply nearly a hundred percent
yes
does that count for something please
yeah if I can clarify the remit in terms
of section 73 applications is left for
professional assessment so an officer
assessment as to the range in scope of
the section 73 so it's not it's not a
criteria based each application is
individually assessed to consider
whether it can be dealt with through a
section 73 application and in this case
it has been that that process has been
worked through and we're confident that
this falls within a section 73 facility
so that's your question case of Safari
chair wants to come back
because it is conditioned to that I have
particular concerns with and I do
believe we have planning reasons to
refuse it basically the visual impact of
the development would be exacerbated by
an additional 15 years and there would
also be effectively development on the
character of the neighborhood by having
it for an additional 15 years so I would
like to propose refusal against on the
basis of material planning reasons
against condition 2 before members make
the vote
I think I'm duty bound to just remind
you of the previous reasons for refusal
which were dismissed by the inspector
just just to request you I've got them
in summary for you in the inspectors
assessment of his main issue just to
remind you so it was previously refused
with respect to the effect upon that
character in appearance the area
including any in cumulative impact with
the approved solar farms at Drayton
Blackwell and Norton Hall now that was
the first reason for refusal and the
second one was the significance of
various heritage assets including the
grade 1 listed church assets within
grade 2 listed stuck way to star listed
Radford manner and the scheduled ancient
monument from Lyon Hill so the inspector
has previously considered I just want to
make it make it clear the character and
appearance of the area include
cumulative impact but however it was
dismissed when considering the
application for a 25 year period before
those reasons you've just exactly set
that point it was based on 25 years not
on 40 years and it is an additional 60%
increase on the impact as far as the
character of the neighborhood the times
increased by 60%
that's what there's a lot of concern
over the road just make sure we we are
clear before we go to it we've had a
proposal at the moment but we have
another second there so before we move
on just to make sure we've got all the
facts in front of us so we make a proper
planning base decision all that can come
back in with some more clarification
apologize if I'm laboring this point the
inspector in his decision letter said
the adverse effects on the character and
appearance of the site and surroundings
I've identified would be limited to a
period of 25 years as councillor Perry
as has flagged up and would be
reversible solar farms are not precluded
within the countryside or this lct and
it is almost inevitable that there will
be some adverse impact
I shall attach moderate weight to this
harm in the overall planning
now the assessment that the inspector
tree was that there was moderate weight
in terms of the harm I appreciate that
relates to 25 years so you are taller he
was I think you do need to focus on the
additional the harm from that additional
period if you are moving towards a
refusal and then catch the mouse okay so
Perry first now I was just wanting to
agree with Karen the fact that she
emphasized the inspectors remarks were
based on 25 years there is a significant
difference between 25 and 40 years and
there's a cumulative buildup apart from
that and 40 years is not temporary
permission it is permanent so I think 25
and 40 years are still temporary as far
as I'm 40 I mean after 25 years it stops
and after 40 years it stopped so it is a
temporary permission although it does go
on for 25 to 40 years I think you know
that can some else did you indicate your
honors come back yeah I think there's on
the same lines as council power I say
not being here on the first hearing on
this on the first application I was just
trying to get my head around this it's
that the inspector said it is 25-year
that this was for 25 years the first one
yeah it was for 25 years yes yes it was
yes and now it going for 40 years
I think we'll we'll move on we catch the
pipe are you making a proposal yes I am
because I believe there is a significant
difference between 25 and 40 years and
as as far as I'm concerned the
additional 15 years represents a 60%
increase of impact to the character of
the neighborhood and also the visual an
impact the development because it's
there longer you know the villagers have
accepted the 25 years on appeal and to
come back and want 40 years you know why
don't they come back in 20 years and ask
for an extension but to ask for it now I
think it's a cumulative impact and I
think particularly when we've got so
many objectives we need to be listening
to our residents those in refusal just
refusal against condition - that's
that's that's the condition I'm refusing
condition - which is the additional 15
years so I'm just checking with offices
much Charlie right have we a seconder
for that proposal yes mr. chairman
okay so Mills
we just go we need to what is the
committee's or cancer Paris it means
she's proposing what's your position on
condition four please
I don't have any material planning
reasons on condition for dis condition -
okay I will go further than has been
said because I think condition 4 is
related because if you listen to what
Karen just read out from the inspectors
report it's specifically related to the
impact over a 25-year period not only
are we
or is there being proposed some
significant amendments to the plans they
may have been assessed professionally
but I disagree with that assessment and
the thing is it is sufficient I think to
require refusal on condition for because
the impact over a 40-year period will be
considerably greater than what was
considered by the inspector and perhaps
the proposals of second as of just ask
that question cats this ain't just the
clarification through uture they
proposed amendments the alterations in
terms of the infrastructure equipment
for maintaining and operation of the of
the solar farm I think he's a separate
matter to the to the extension to the
time period realistically we may well we
may well have the applicants coming back
to us in the event of a refusal and
and seeking to to have these changes in
terms of the equipment for a 25 year
period can we just clarify and I
appreciate the agents in the in the room
that you your concerns are about or
interlinked with the 40 with with the
extension to 40 days that you are not
objecting to these amendments per se to
put your microphone on please
I am objecting to the amendments per se
because they represent in my view a
significant change to the original
application
right um first of all I think we'll go
with counselor Perry who's happy as a
propose up just to go on condition - and
you're not again the Tamil if I'm
putting words on your mouth are you
happy to accept condition for or you
just want to stick to your original
proposal of just condition - to be
honest with you they are interlinked in
terms of what council Saint has said
because obviously the existence of the
buildings for 40 years it's all it is
interlinked so I'm quite happy to go for
a futile
based on two and four thank you
interlinked you're saying that there
will be additional harm significant harm
I'm just trying to see it's it's it's
obviously it's that the character that
the neighborhood if the solar farm is
there for 40 years all of its
infrastructure has them has a cumulative
impact catch the bombs
if toddler it hasn't affected for 40
years the whole site rule about
appreciated I've refused his lifetime
but we're in a different ballgame
if the 40 years he's going to make a big
difference
he's not only going to be because of the
panel this began again they just so cute
and everything else think well we'll go
to the right now I think catch the Perry
is proposed refusal because of the harm
on condition to run condition for
cumulative and I'm for caring and the
weeds will come up with procurement
ology depending on on the vote so we've
had a proposal to refuse the application
and seconded by Councillor Mills all
those in favor
for chairman against its region
committee resolves to refuse application
so the word 18 / 0 T 3 so my very and
will will sort out the final wording
with the share yes we'll just have a
temporary German for five minutes
and with us move on to our next
application which is 18/36 1/6 ful by
treeborn Front Street Ellington's CB 36
single story expansion and the first
floor extension over existing insertion
of conservation roof light reshaping of
existing gamma windows removal chimney
and dom on the rear elevation
installation of replacement windows and
bi-fold doors the rear demolition of
existing single-story extension and
presenting officer thank you very thank
you chair the application AB for members
is seeking planning permission for a
single-story rear extension and for a
first for extension over an existing
rear extension those are the further
amendments and that includes the
reshaping of existing rear dormers the
removal of a chimney or evil of one rear
dormer and also the addition of a
conservation style roof on the rear roof
slope apologies the application site is
identified by the black dot and is
situated within the village of Illman
turn so the application site is outlined
here in red and as you can see the
application site is located between two
three two listed buildings so we've got
hob days here and hob days barn here the
site is also situated within the village
Conservation Area along with the
Cotswolds a OMB bay tree barn is a
detached two-story dwelling constructed
of stone so here we've got an aerial
photo view and it just demonstrates the
relationship between the application
site and the nearby neighboring
properties here we've got the existing
plans and elevations along with the so
sorry the existing floor plans along
with the front rear and south side
elevations of the dwelling now turning
to the proposed floor plans so as you
can see the new walls are shown here in
pink
and also the proposed elevations
so the East South and West elevations
along with cross-sections and this is
the existing and proposed north side
elevation where we can see the extent of
that first floor extension here so movin
on out some images of the application
site so here we've got some views from
the street scene a front Lane the map
here just demonstrating where those wet
sand been taken from and here we've got
the front elevation of the dwelling and
this is the rear elevation and some
closer up views of the rear elevation
and here we've got a view of the
property particularly you can see the
North elevation here and this is taken
from front Lane and here it's the first
image I've got the North elevation so
it's taken from the garden of the
neighboring property hog days barn so
this is here is where the first work
Center will be another photo taken from
the garden of hog days barn and a
further photo taken but from within the
corner so you can see the conservatory
here this is hot days barn conservatory
and this is the application dwelling
just one further photo sorry taken even
further back you can see here the wall
of the other neighbor of property Henok
Lodge here on the right hand side so
updates since the printing of the report
the spoke consultation was undertaking
was it was undertaken sorry with the
conservation officer comments have been
received and added to the update sheet
just to summarize no objection was
raised in regards to the impact on the
setting of the two neighboring listed
buildings and also amended plans have
been received yesterday in respect of
the existing chimney on the North
elevation which hadn't been shown drawn
to scale it should be noted however that
the works that Jimmy did not form part
of the development proposal
and this too has been created on the
update sheet so chairman it's
recommended to grant the application for
the reason set out on the report which
can be found on page 21 of the agenda
Thank You Louise excuse me come over our
first speaker which is Nikki slaughter
and John Sherwood are you both talking I
was one speaking
thank you John you've got three minutes
and I'll give you a warning shot with it
okay you've got three minutes anyway
thank you I'm speaking on behalf of the
owner of hot days foreign and immediate
neighbors along with the parish council
we object to this application because of
the overbearing nature and loss of
amenity that this two-story extension
would cause to the grade 2 listed hobb
days barn
we're also troubled by the planning
departments assessment process in this
case for the following reasons
accurate information an inaccurate
elevation that contains at least two
errors was used by all planning
departments and the committee to assess
the application the revised one was only
posted yesterday this calls into
question what planners counselors and
the conservation officer were basing
their decisions on and what other errors
might exist in the plans due diligence
and an open mind if the district
councillors felt it necessary to make a
site visit to the property most affected
prior to their determination then we
would have thought the case officers
would have done the same neither case
officer visited the site before making
their decision to grant the present case
officer only reviewed the previous case
officers information and photos before
making her decision rather than looking
at the application of fresh with a site
visit particularly in light of the
area's sensitivity the neighbors
objections and the committee's decision
to defer based on this can she have made
her determination with an open mind
additionally photos cannot convey the
true impact on immunity from within the
house the view from the bedroom windows
the garden and the street scene the
conservation officer states that the
existing single-story extension already
has an overbearing and sense of height
over hobb days barn and that if the tall
side wall extension didn't exist the
creation of a two-story extension would
likely cause harm her conclusion to
grant then seems contradictory as this
is exactly what the application is for a
two-story extension
she also says the addition of a pitch
roof is unlikely to alter the current
arrangement enough to judge that the
listed building setting and appreciation
of it would be negatively impacted the
addition of a pitch roof would add three
metres in height
making it 10 meters from the apex to the
garden of hot days barn the equivalent
of a three-story building if the
existing extension is already deemed to
be overbearing then surely the addition
of the three meters in height will
exacerbate the situation to reiterate
the proposed extension sits between two
listed buildings in a conservation area
and a o and B where the ground level of
the listed Hobday sparked is one point
eight in meters excuse me meters below
that of the applicants dwelling based on
the potential harm to hobb days barn
setting and amenity we request the
counselors refused this application
regardless of the decision you make we
want to thank the counselors first
reassessing the application and making
the site visit thank you very much you
have just any before go into questions
again it's to make it clear that
officers might break into
recommendations it's the cancer sumac
the actual decisions and as you see from
the previous application they do go
against officers recommendations so
that's the point of having site visits
to clarify issues
we deferred the original application so
I think we have been extremely fair on
this application and obviously then we
also have the ward member who knows the
area well and he or she will come and
give their perspective as well so we are
trying to be as transparent as possible
and so I hope you appreciate that okay
after my little speech there any
questions mr. Perry thank you and good
evening
I just wondered whether you can confirm
the type of window that is in the
first-floor bedroom the type of window
it was she lives there and I'm the Velux
is in the roof at a normal angle it is
thank you
I know I'm not here and they have
actually objected the parish council you
didn't happen did you actually attend
the price council meet and when they my
decision to object or do you know any
reasons can I also share that the parish
councillors we contacted them they're
about here personal reasons they
couldn't come tonight and we did ask if
I could present on their behalf because
I'm the former chairman and yeah yeah
but it was no no it I was told that they
could have delegated had they been
giving it they'd given written notice in
time but it was only today so that's
yeah but I'm also chairman of the
neighborhood plan committee so they
thought there was a symmetry there okay
yep thank you very much yeah any further
questions thank you ladies you're you're
free to go I'm very much
come on next speaker is mr. dan Jackson
I'll sleep in here before mr. Jackson
you've got three minutes yes thank you
very much good evening everyone
I'm here today to speak on behalf of my
clients in support of this household of
planning application I thank the
planning officers for their constructive
feedback and assistance to date and
fully endorse their positive
recommendation for approval the scheme
as you'll see is for a pitch roof
extension over an existing single-story
rear extension it uses materials that
match the existing batery barn and is
cited to the rear and side elevations
objections have been raised as you've
heard of overshadowing and overlooking
into the neighboring properties
particularly the greater listed hot days
barn and also so I think harm to the
conservation area the committee's
request the conservation officer has
been consulted again and does not object
to the scheme she states that was the
pitch roof addition will be partially
visible from the street scene it is more
in keeping with the local vernacular
than the existing Molly pitch roof and
will not cause harm to the character or
appearance of the conservation area the
sections on the screen demonstrate that
the extension is slightly lower than the
existing parapet roof and the height of
the existing extension and the pitch
roof nature of it allows the first floor
to be inserted without the need for
boundary walls to hop say it's barn to
be extended any higher than they
currently are in light of this and the
17 meter distance from hop dais barn the
scheme will not overshadow nor will it
be significantly over there in the
planning and conservation officers agree
that as the dwelling has an existing
roots tension the pitch roof addition
will not alter this enough to negatively
affect the setting of hop dais barn to
ensure no loss of privacy for the
neighbors no windows are sited on this
elevation facing the property and only
warm first-floor window is on the rear
elevation which - not directly face any
dwellings and does not breach the 45
degree rule into any habitable
windows the block plan illustrates that
the site into sorry the block plan
illustrates in red that the two small
areas of land weather is potentially
overlooking from the extension both to
hobb days barn the and the gravel
driveway which is not usable garden
space it should be noted that the Parish
Council objection the parish councils
objection on overlooking grounds relates
solely to a Juliet balcony which was
subsequently removed from the plans in
accordance with policy CF 20 the
proposal doesn't unacceptably detract
from the amenities of neighboring
properties nor will it adversely impact
the setting of the list of building
through lots of light privacy dominance
overlooking or overshadowing we believe
this is a great scheme and hope that's a
straightforward decision to approve the
application in line with the officers
recommendation and the conservation
officers comments thank you any
questions for the agent cast aside Jim
I'm slightly confused it might be my
recollection of drawings is wrong but
I'm sure that when we were shown the
existing and the proposed changes one
above the other that's the one yeah and
that's the one now there the peach roof
on the extension seems to be at a
similar height to the pitch roof on the
main building which faces the road so
can you comment on any difference there
please because normally our design
guides recommends that it should be
subservient how much lower
straining a lot imagine
600ml not just Intel yes we've just had
a rolling glare from Louisa right moving
on any any further questions to show any
further and you further questions thank
you very much you're free to go catch
the brain would you like to speak on
this one
I guess like five minutes so far away
Chairman I support both the objectors on
the publish Council you know objecting
to this application indeed I attended
the published council meeting last week
and that asked me if I would attend and
speak on it so we're together on this
consideration for this application or
the conservation area a OMB and to grade
2 listed buildings these are significant
alterations the committee have already
had the benefit of an earlier debate and
a site visit to know that this
application for a single story really
extended and first floor extension has
not been fully assessed as it conflicts
with his policy cs8 by the overbearing
nature of proposed development would in
my opinion cause significant harm to
both the great two listed buildings and
impact on the amenities of both by its
height or mats and overshadowing cs9
design and distinctiveness the extender
will be visible from the road will
affect the street scene in the engine
conservation area
indeed the conservation officer said it
will be seen from the road CS 15 in my
opinion his proposal will be harmful to
by having an unreasonable impact on the
surrounding landscape and setting of the
settlement by virtue of its overbearing
boat maps and shadowing committee I
would respectfully request that you
refuse his planning permission for this
current proposal and the current and
that the applicant seeks to revise that
proposal in light of the objections
raised chairman thank you cats the brain
any questions for the ward member no
you're free to go sir
thank you right move on two points of
clarification Claire Safari Thank You
chair I would just quite like to know
whether the case officer actually when
visiting hobb days was able to go up to
the to the first floor bedroom which is
without giving too much information is
also a living space as well the
objectives already confirmed
it's a Velux window which obviously is
at that angle and on the site visit we
did go up to that to the first floor the
reason why I'm raising that is I'm
concerned that the whole of the window
from where you're standing would be
filled by the proposed new development
therefore blocking out light but if the
case officer hadn't been to the first
bedroom
they wouldn't appreciate the impact on
the neighboring community
I can come in the first case officer did
the site did his site visit and did a
review of the relationship from from
outside the neighboring property but we
have photographs showing the deihi here
and did a took a photograph which pretty
much accorded with the the previous one
so that was so he would have been able
to see hot days bomb and seemed at the
rear but he didn't go in to the first
floor which is a living space as well as
a bedroom yeah that would that would not
follow our normal practice we have
authority to enter land when site visits
are done you would expect to be to be
able to access the site itself it's very
unusual to to then
explicitly visit and enter adjoining
properties and certainly it's very
unusual to to to I anticipate and expect
to be able to to review an adjoining
property internally thank you do we know
[Music]
the dikes in the Sun is that going to
cause a problem shadow when this if this
extension goes on do we know sir Sun
tracks east to west in the pattern which
you can see I'm drawing with my mouse
like that it starts over here Rises and
then sets over in the West does that
help
so there would be a significant changes
in there the report doesn't doesn't
conclude that there'll be a harmful
overshadow an impact that there will be
the officer report doesn't conclude that
there will be
ya think ya at this point is that the
various between the seasons of men I
realize their seasons mr. chairman but
even in the no matter where winter or
summer the some settles down and get to
lower shadow right any further points of
clarification the bonds the mass of the
building I thought was inappropriate I
also felt that it had a more damaging
effect on the house next door which I
went because you can see the whole of
the one side of the building only plus
the mrs. no on the right-hand side
that's it yes Leslie it's going to be
substantially bigger and I think that
there would have a major effect on next
door because I didn't get for me in the
dog went next door so as far as I'm
concerned
no it just needs to be down a bit bit
more thoughts who got into it and it
might be alright
but sighs Balkan mass in my eyes is too
great although the conservation
architect and they usually oppose
everything seem to think it's okay but
those are my thoughts
that's the balance why there please
Thank You chair I think I think this
application the problem the problem with
it is exacerbated because there is a
difference and electively we were
informed on the site visit was a 10
meter difference in height between one
property and the next property
I've already highlighted the the relaxed
window issue because basically when
you're standing in the the bedroom the
hold of that window with the proposed
development you know you wouldn't see
any sky at all just brick because of the
angle of of the window so therefore and
coupled with the orientation of the Sun
and its movement my own view is I would
like to propose refusal on grounds of
the impact of overbearing nature of the
proposed development and the adverse
effect on the residential immunity of
the neighbors thanks for chairman now
yeah it is a significant alteration to
this basic building and Peter bonsai
from from this angle it when we stood in
the garden it did not I could imagine
it's very very overbearing so you know
we're on the conservation area I'm I'm
amazed and it's listed this building
listed it's not listed ok but in a
conservation area and either a big slab
there I mean I it's but I can't go with
it how to go against the obvious
recommendation thank you
against the science yes chairman if I
can observe on page 29 there is a
paragraph or two here headed impact on
parking which is a subject quite near to
my heart as you will know it's something
I raised quite frequently so I'm just
going to observe for this evening that
I'm pleased to see that's the draft
parking standards and their guidance are
in fact included in here although I
don't honestly think in this particular
instance this is a has a significant
bearing on the application I until four
years ago was the ward member for
roaming Tanana 'changes saw that it was
taken away from me and therefore I'm
familiar with this part of the village
and indeed batery barn is a not listed
building surrounded by listed properties
and therefore it's a very difficult one
the slope of the land puts it up above
the listed properties from the lady that
was sat over there and effectively
therefore puts it in a difficult
position for them to put such a large
extension on to that particular building
now I agree with councillor Mills that
the existing building is in fact an
imposition in itself the higher building
will be even more so doesn't matter what
people say bad impact I think will be
significant and you know it's it's a
case whereby I think we do want the roof
to be subservient I accept it's 600
metres if that's what Louise has
measured it as you know the issue though
is it wants to be a lot lower
not quite have the the the internal
accommodation along that face that faces
up to the nearby listed building hob
days barn and one or two others that are
in that little coal de sac which
contains the hob days barns so
consequently we have a situation whereby
we have as Council of barn says both
mass and everything else that we don't
usually use those terms where you do
ESA's we change the policy but with the
core strategy but effectively that that
is the problem with this application
it's right on the border of the neighbor
and it has far too great an impact for
me to be able to support the application
bonds would you be win to second example
if cancer Perry is my proposal yeah I
think I think cancer probably did sign
up but again it's better to say it twice
and not say to yourself I guess the
bottom so right we've had a proposal and
a second to refuse applications just
clarified that just make sure we have
had some comments in the update sheet
about the conservation area so I know
there was some comments back on but
that's not as part of just clarify that
as well so we've had excuse me a
proposal to refuse and second the trees
the application all those in favor
please check okay I've come up with a
draft reason for fusil in light of the
discussion which has taken place
so the first for extension by reason of
its size Volker mass is considered to
introduce an unacceptable overbearing
impact on the amenities of the
neighboring property hog days barn this
harm is further exacerbated by the
change in ground levels orientation of
the neighbor and the width of the garden
the proposal is therefore contrary to
policy cs9 and also the guidance within
extent in your home chair sorry to
interject could we also make reference
to the orientation of the Sun the loss
of light butts impacting on the because
of the bulk and mass setting in the West
no Jared be very cautious about
overshadowing because we are we are
talking in relation just to the garden
are you happy to go with the the we said
exactly what I was going to say before I
was interrupted by basis I thank you for
Barnes happy to a second on those on
what condition you're right I'll move on
before I get interrupted again by my
legal adviser in kind of proposal to
refuse application all those in favor of
the refusal application well thank you
rather than ketchup and we'll move on to
our next application which is 1900 139
FPL lund off Banbury Road Britain prize
sorry cancer I don't know
erection of three bedroom drumming house
item number five on the agenda cancer
bonds getting our money's worth from you
to various thank you thank you chair the
application out for members is seeking
planning permission for the construction
of a detached three-bedroom dwelling
house the application site is identified
by the black dot and it's situated in
the village of penitent priors the site
is outlined here in red the site
comprises a vacant plot of land situated
amongst existing residential dwellings
so here we've got an aerial photo to
demonstrate the relationship between the
site and the nearby surrounding pattern
of development got home stores meadow
here to the west new tree house is here
to the east Brook house is situated here
to the south so here we've got the
proposed site layout also show in the
creation of a new access onto the bumpy
road and driveway parking for two
vehicles so moving onto the proposed
floor plans we've got the ground floor
plan here and the first floor plan here
showing the three bedrooms and here
we've got the proposed elevations front
rear and a two sides so moving on to
some images of the application site so
the first image here is views towards
the front of the site taken from Bambury
road so you've got brick house which is
here situated behind the site new tree
house is over here and this is just a
photo taken just looking within the site
so again new tree house here
and here we can see some views from the
street scene of Bambury roads that the
site is just here this is number one
home stall Meadows the slightly rag and
new tree house here this is taken from
the position shown here so that's new
tree house roof there the hedge line
along you treehouse site is just there
and another photo looking from the other
end of bamboo Road and these next images
of our neighboring dwellings again new
tree house number one home stalls Meadow
Brook house and also this is the
opposite the application site so you've
got the rear elevation of Gables here so
in terms of updates we've got two
additional conditions suggested in
regarding land contamination or
remediation work which were originally
suggested by the Environmental Health
Team however these were what we missed
off the report by mistake and chairman
it's recommended to grant the
application for the reason set out in
the report which can be found on page 33
of the agenda Thank You Maurice our
first speakers which are soo greener and
Dominic Stanton from for the term priors
obviously got three minutes between you
and again we'll give you a warning with
about 30 seconds to go and if we could
just put the microphone
Hooten Prize Parish Council object to
this application this small area of land
been left over grown since home stall
Meadows was built 20 years ago and had
become a home for wildlife along a nap
and a natural barrier from the noise and
light from the a4 to to to the
surrounding properties because the main
hedge that you can see here was around 6
meters high and over a meter thick it
came as a major shock to the parish
council when the hedge was removed and
sight roughly cleared and a farm gate
installed we believe this is country to
policy cs5 and cs6 which seeks to
protect and enhance the landscape with
absolutely no communication between the
developer and the parish council the
next we knew was the original planning
application although this second
application has removed the garage and
made changes to the main building we
feel the size and design of the property
it's still too large and overbearing for
the size and shape of this small plot
the presenting officers report states
that it only just meets the extend your
home minimum requirements within a
thirteen point six meters
against the minimum of 13 meters this
looks to be the largest property that
can be shoehorned into this plot its
height and mass will affect neighboring
properties contrary to policy cs10 which
seeks to minimize the impact on existing
properties how any smoke from the
trailing chimney won't infiltrate any of
the neighboring properties has not been
identified policy a as 10 seeks to
minimize the impact on existing
properties this application does not
minimize as it affects the residential
private amenity of existing properties
bordering the site and those on the
other side of the a4 to to another major
failing is the availability or the
visibility visibility display without
the owner of you treehouse allowing
their hedge to be
cut back which they will not we believe
this is not achievable the report says
that the pruning required to create
display falls within the adopted
highways this is contrary to when the
county council undertook some
maintenance of this hedge and confirmed
to the parish council in an email dated
11 to the 10th 2015 that it was not
theirs and would instruct the occupier
of you treehouse that is their
responsibility this hedge is already on
the boundary of the highways our two
parking spaces sufficient for a
3-bedroom property Novus to space these
are questions I think you need to answer
these spaces are on the boundary of the
rear of the garden and seating area of
yew tree house so the movement of
vehicles at this location will have a
detrimental effect on their private
residential immunity with either
headlights shining directly into the
rear windows or exhaust fumes
contaminating in we urge you to refuse
this application to over develop this
site any questions to the site yes
chairman mr. Sandt refers to the
visibilities plays within there can you
give us some guidance as to how much
rear garden this proposed property would
have a ditch disposal very little if
none thank you so will again will
clarify a lot with the offices there is
a you didn't mention about the
visibility supplies not thought you're
going to go on to that connection site
probably is covered in page 41 that
County hires to confirm that the
visibility spray is required for the new
access would fall entirely within an
adopted highway as such any works 2h7
required to achieve with visibility
expires can thus be carried out so I
think
we've seem to have answered that
question now I mean sorry I'm NotI asked
it but effectively what we were told a
moment ago was that it required the
neighbors hedge to be cut back in order
to provide the visibility splays perhaps
we can get some clarification yeah that
the adopted highway what maintenance to
the adopted highway would effectively
you know the County Council for that
area what was here and there's now gone
but yeah do I understand you're not a
posted development on the site you just
opposed to the size of this development
has been proposed as a parish council we
work very closely with the developers
we're certainly working with Deeley
homes who are currently developing ten
properties in the village and we've been
very active in that proposal I think
with this plot it's so small in our
views it's an over development of a site
I don't think that quite answered what I
was asking are you opposed to any
development of the site or not yes thank
you
Safari good evening I wonder whether you
can clarify your views on the impact
that the character of this particular
street scene by the removal of the
hedgerow in terms of place setting
within Puritan priors it was quite a
shocking loss to the village heads it
disappeared over a day
it was literally flailed to the ground
and its disappearance has had quite a
big impact visually on one Street
can I just come back in terms of where
the access is because obviously the
picture that we've is that a historical
picture is that how it is now that's the
historical picture of how it so we
haven't got a picture yes I was in
Malaysia officer how it looks fine okay
yeah so that's how it actually looks now
but on the previous image that you could
see there was no gateway at all it was
just pure edge when the hedge was
cleared that gateway was inserted and
there's no drop curb it was never there
was never an official access on to that
site it was just complete heads any
further questions thank you very much
you're free to go and next speaker is
mr. mark Minton
I didn't think you were here for a
minute I'm hit
everyone that's written in objecting to
this proposal three minutes isn't long
enough to address all of our objections
adequately adequately unfortunately
that's all you got so you try that are
your best place lots of privacy loss of
natural direct sunlight the oversized
nature of the building in relation to
the plot size are only some of our
objections
we've decided to focus primarily on to
which we feel more relevant firstly the
applicant states that the plot is vacant
and without vegetation well this is the
case now but only after a quite brutal
and barbaric clearance which evolved
flailing of two hedges one blind to my
property one belonging to another one of
my neighbors there was no consultation
whatsoever
at any point the dense vegetation on the
site which you've seen on the
photographs has gone as has a 19 to 20
meter run off the hedge which was very
well established and some 20 feet in
height core strategy cs9 requires among
other things sensitivity it's our
understanding that cs9 has already been
contravened because the action taken by
the the applicant is certainly not
environmentally sensitive and in no way
give the actions to be described as
sensitive toward the neighboring
properties and residents I would also
like to address the issue of the
proposed access into the site off the
main a four to two boundary to Stratford
Road the applicant admits to providing
the Highway Authority with detailed plan
showing achievable visibility space we
can only believe that highways must have
assumed that these required 70 meter
visibility displays could be achieved
based on the information provided it's
simply not the case in order to achieve
a 70 meter visibility display to the
east ahead
h7 would have to be severely cut back a
point conceded by the applicant in their
commissioned our War II cultural report
section 1.8 which states and I quote in
order to facilitate a new access
Junction into the site the hedgerow 87
will require remedial pruning well this
particular hedges in my ownership and I
most definitely won't want or allow this
to happen
so without a 70 meter visibility splay
being achievable the highways non
objection is rendered invalid I don't
know there will be a clear and evident
health and safety issue which in turn
contradicts cs9 quite clearly that a
development has to be safe and healthy
for this one reason alone we would ask
that this application be rejected out of
hand or at the very least deferred so
that the site meeting can be held to
verify that what we are saying is fact
hopefully at that point that committee
would be left in no doubt about the
validity of our objection and the very
real issues relating to safety questions
for mr. Linton catch the pairing
good evening still in sight I just
wonder whether you could just give a
little bit more detail about your
boundary hedge we've heard from we've
we've already heard that it's all it's
been confirmed by the officers that it's
actually on highways land obviously an
element of the front bit would be on
highways and but how far does the the
hedge go back into your property the
hedges on our land in no way effects or
overhangs the public right away which is
the footpath to the side of the 840 t
one other thing that I would like to say
as well is it I don't know how
older hedge has to be classified as to
be historic but it's a box hedge very
very mature and it's got to be at least
well over 75 years old it offers a huge
acoustic and visual barrier to the busy
a42 road for our property so any what
any amount of pruning is going to have
an adverse effect on our property and
without chopping it back the 70 meter
display to the east just can't be
achieved
again nothing well our surfaces as well
for their views on that as well
any further questions and that you're
free to go mr. Newton thank you very
much thank you and our next speaker
please which is mr. Tim Farley
good evening you've got six minutes mr.
Farley mr. chairmembers
thank you for the opportunity to speak
tonight in support of the proposal I'd
also like to thank the planning officer
Louise for working with us practically
to address the material planning
considerations and to bring the proposal
into a form that could be recommended
for approval I believe that the officers
report is clear and well reasoned so the
points already seek to address the
concerns highlighted and objections by
neighbors and other interested parties
the history of the sites is accurately
presented in the planning report the
parcel of land has been held by a family
for decades and it's always been the
intention to develop it at some point
one member of the family is a developer
based in Melbourne Derbyshire who builds
extremely high quality homes to a
conservation standard and has more a
number of awards for design quality in
recent years the bespoke design of this
home has been refined through the course
of two plan applications so that it
meets the necessary design spatial and
separation standards of this Authority
and of the county counts one parking
maneuvering space access and visibility
displays the standards are being met
distance separation standards to protect
the privacy delight and outlook of the
neighboring properties have been met and
since the proposal meets these standards
and has more than 100 square meters of
amenity space to the rear it's
considered unreasonable to conclude that
the proposal somehow represents over
development of the site there are no
symptoms of favored development the very
first thing we did on the project was
contact the County Highways Department
to make sure that we could meet the
necessary highway standards for
visibility splays and safe access
and we were encouraged by the positive
responses to the pre-application inquiry
and both of the planning applications I
understand that there is particular
concern about Treaty five I thought he
might be mentioned earlier but he hasn't
been which was identified by a tree
specialist as being a category u tree
and therefore at the end of its life and
could potentially become dangerous
imminently the tree is within the
boundary of the site but it actually
could be unaffected by the development
in its amended form my clients has
confirmed that if it is essential for
safety reasons that the tree is removed
then he would undertake to replace it
with a semi mature tree of the same
species which I believe is in Cherry as
a part of a comprehensive landscaping
scheme which will be designed to enhance
visual immunity biodiversity and privacy
for future occupants and for the
existing neighbors in conclusion we
believe the proposal represents a high
quality addition to the street scene
sympathetic to the character of the area
and to the amenities of the neighbors
the site is a windfall site in a
sustainable location around the whole
the proposal fully complies with the
local and national planning policies
thank you for your time thank you thank
you and thank you for waiting this
evening cuz I know you've had a long
wait with a lot of the other people I
just wonder whether you can advise what
engagement in consultation you've done
with that the applicant has done with
the neighbors and also the parish
council there wasn't any engagement with
the parish council all the neighbors so
no no engagement the parish council and
no engagement with neighbors that's
great the bonds you probably heard that
last speaker was I had the visibility's
present he staged the counter you don't
appear to have a problem is it your head
you're I'm gonna look to the offices and
legal offices but my understanding is
that it's the neighbors hedge but if it
overhangs highway if it were hangs
highway land and if for example if it
was starting to gray towards the
carriageway
then the highest authority could cut it
themselves or they could require for the
owner of the hedge to cut it but the
fact is yes maybe the neighbors heads
and the reefs are in the it Springs from
the neighbours land but given this is
overhanging the highway if it impedes
visibilities plays or the safe safety of
pedestrians or vehicles then it can be
[Music]
we will I think just mentioned in the
report on page 41 about the visitors
displays but again we'll seek
clarification from the offices young I
didn't on to that point against the
bonds is that I think I could see what
is going on and I thought you might just
lid on a bit further about how your
proposals will fit in and be sympathetic
to the current existing street scene and
character of the village could you
demonstrate how you how you feel that
what happened well I think that the the
design of the building was done by
architects who basically conservation
architects based in this field and they
had a look at a lot of the buildings in
the surrounding area in coming up with
the design
so based on the local vernacular
obviously we have one opportunity for
which is the Banbury Road there are
hedges and fences and houses it's a
mishmash and so the fact that the hedge
has gone or been reduced and will be
replaced and strengthened and improved
through landscaping scheme it would the
appearance of the site will be different
but I think that we're presenting a
beautiful face but a building to the
Boundary Road to contribute to enhance
the street scene be more questions for
mr. Farley the building 15 30 meters
more than 30 meters
since the site yes chairman could we
have the previous diagram back please
that's right now if you remember earlier
I asked the parish councillors about the
amount of land to the rear and I can't
see on that diagram where your rear
boundary is so can you help me out of
that
but I just followed that up in chairman
okay thank you for that the bit at the
side to the to what I might call the Ox
hillside
that's it rather than the edingtons side
is that land there that's included
within this side sorry I don't quite
understand which part you're referring
to so there's a black there's a black
line where the cursor is going up and
down that's the side boundary
Oh on the previous application we had
proposed a single garage and then it was
felt they would have an overbearing
impact on the neighbors to that site so
we removed the single garage and have no
plans to put it back right mr. Farley I
think you're free to go now
thank you very much right our next
speaker is that the ward member can't
slow down on
Thank You chair I'm really interested to
learn that there has always been the
intention to develop this plot of land
because there has never been a right of
access applied for so it doesn't
something very well planned out
and the lack of respect the ecology the
hedgerows the Radisson residents the
lack of engagement with really active
and super parish council lead might have
grave concerns about this application
and given the layout of the site I would
actually urge you to defer and grant a
site visit the case is site-specific
throughout your deliberations please
note that the plot is on the busy a four
to two where we are currently
experiencing increased traffic through
the new visitor attraction caffeine in
the Machine and as a lot of speeding
issues around there and I mention this
because when I visited residents on the
application site I was struck by the
speed and volume of traffic on the a
four to two and it's concerning that an
access was simply put in without a drop
curb and a farmer's gate it just
appeared overnight and the proud
canceled have previously noted that the
dimensions of the plot they believe are
19 meters wide and 23 meters deep which
suggested the proposed build would be
over development of the site as I say
there's been no engagement to the
applicant in the parish council all the
neighboring properties which given the
potential impacted this application
which it will have upon their lives is
really rather unfortunate as well as the
disregard for cs6 and the manner with
which the site was cleared and those
hedges really were hacked if you
consider cs9 requires new development to
complement and enhance the character of
its context who's sensitive sighting and
lay out a respecting local topography
and landscape features this surely
contravenes it i've noticed the
overbearing aspect of the application to
the neighboring properties louise has
highlighted three properties however
when i visited the site of note with the
builds proximity to the numbers 1 to 3
of home stores meadow plus the build
looking directly into the bedroom and
living room at number 5 home stores
meadow and again this would be seen on a
site visit plus this site is elevated in
relation to the properties opposite the
property's opposite include the gables
and saddle stones these little lower
than the plot and will suffer from
headlights shining directly into their
properties and this contra is a s10 if a
site visit is granted the proposed
sighting size shape for the application
and the issues regarding the neighboring
properties will become apparent
looking to cs5 where we as a council
look to protect hedgerows and trees
especially those which serve to
contribute to the public community and
the six meter high one meter thick hedge
provided an acoustic barrier and visual
protection from headlights to the
neighboring properties yes even more
this would have to be removed to allow
for the vital visibility splays is
requested by highways it seems rather
unfair to the residents considering the
lack of engagement and the pruning
advice - 87 is pruning without the
permission of the yew tree residents
they're stoned visibility there are
currently a highway there is County a
highway sign which was the visible on
one of the photographs for an upcoming
junction just in front of the new
entrance which shows you that it wasn't
really thought-out and this sign will
also impact on visibility now back into
February before the increased traffic
flow with the caffeine in the Machine
which I know is the planning issue but
it doesn't implicate on volume of
traffic back into February they said
they didn't have any objections but they
did actually put a number of conditions
on that and one of the highways
conditions was that the access to the
site the vehicle should not be used
unless a public highway foot way verge
crossing has been laid out and
constructed in accordance with the
standard specification of Highways
Authority and the development could not
be occupied until visibilities place
have been provided to the vehicular
access to the site with an X distance of
2.4 meters and Y distance of 70 meters
to the near edge of the public highway
carriage also of note is that there is
no garage and it's not enough parking
for visitors to visit the site I had to
park on home stores meadow and more than
one person doing this will cause for
visitors parking issues I'm also
concerned from a safety aspect that the
visitors who are able to park on the
plot will have to reverse out due to
this very tight layout I don't believe
that the diagrams fully show you the the
layout of the site also scars parking
along the boundary shared with you tree
house or impact upon the residents to
growth headlights and more worryingly
car exhaust fumes surely not in keeping
with our clean air directives the impact
the chimney emissions on neighboring
property should also be taken into
account so given the cumulative impact
of all of the above I would ask you to
defer and attend as like a site visit or
move to refuse
any questions for the one member no I
think I've got some questions but I
think they're more pertinent to the
officers regarding guys thank you very
much we move on to points of
clarification
I did visit the site yesterday and
almost concern about its visibility
display is it oh we now say always at
highway saying that past that hey
Janelle is on the highways land
essentially the grass verge here and
part of the grass verges over the hedge
h7 here part of you treehouse is
overhanging this verge here which falls
within adopted highways land right so
it's all of a sudden that is highways
after all these years
okay we're just going to say to you no
way it was a highway whether this things
grow or not but well I can't go against
a case on the fraid just one point on
the hedgerows chair and everybody's been
saying about it's been ripped out not in
the corns for cs6 well it would be
ripped out not in accordance with the
hedgerow regulations so it depends
whether it comes under the definition of
a hedgerow in the first place could you
clarify that Louise I don't know I don't
care I was just checking with it he came
yes there is no protection for the hood
drove through the planning legislation
the protection protection lease through
the hedgerows legislation that's very
specific in terms of the types of
pedro's that are protected was
appreciate that there was a comment from
the the neighbor about works being done
to his hedgerow that's not a planning
matter that's a private matter between
himself and the landowner developer
chairman
looking at the the layout of the plot I
see two car parking spaces have been
marked now on page 35 under other
relevant documents sorry I'm at it again
it refers to the development
requirements supplementary planning
document part o parking and travel no it
is not as specific as it was in the
previous application which I welcome and
it says this party's of relevance to the
application it's currently under
consultation and therefore has limited
weight in the planning balances
however the consultation has closed and
it's going to come up for adoption in a
matter of weeks can I ask how many
parking spaces will be demanded by that
particular part of the development
requirements as the development proposal
is proposing a three-bedroom dwelling
it's two parking spaces it is - yes
right okay and what about visitors
in the SPD the provision just states two
spaces for a three-bedroom dwelling
house there's the box the clarification
really on this page thing in long Austin
and Mike will probably remember and
somewhere else
the County Council lost their people
through cookies they didn't so the
County Council their camera did it and
shot him up again they soon could he
back there baton they were asked again
so the lore is that if it is a danger it
can be cut down
to come to the microphone please hey
I'll just your point of clarification is
I'm going to use a point of
clarification honestly so it's regarding
the hedgerows with being cut back it's
not a danger because it's not
overhanging the hut they need to be kept
back more in order for the visibility
splays which you need to be passed for
this to be a safe entrance it's not with
regards to it being an on an unsafe
hedge not that's pretty not the right
terminology but you know midstream it
back because it's overhanging on a
public wait path path or foot way it's
not that it has to be hacked back in
order for the visibility splay that's
what the clarification you need it's not
because it's an overhanging hedge that
has been trimmed back does that make
sense yes okay Brian I came to counters
rain this table should know through the
includes visual displays as well it's a
requirement for landowners to keep it
clear and if they don't know the order
can be served on the landowner to cut it
back or the County Council can cut it
back on their behalf isn't that for
existing developments is for a new
development they'd have to come and cut
it back I believe it would be for new
development as well sorry
no that's no it's been out in the
episode thank you for once no should we
move on to the debate then you want to
start on the counterparty Wireless star
you are tonight Wow
and the notes are three-bedroom house
could you tell me what the square
footage is of the plot please
because it looks quite larger and free
they don't allege it's not point not
three hectares proposed well I don't
have the exact square footage figures to
hand I can tell you the garden area if
that would help
sorry the risk you coming back to this
hedge issue and I don't want to go
outside of planning but can Mesa help me
so by paying approving this application
if what we've heard is correct or saying
bypassing this that will require the
neighborhood start to start cutting his
hedge back I just want to be clear on
that because I don't understand at the
moment know what I mean it says here WCC
highways have confirmed that the
visibility spray required for the new
axis would fall entirely within an
adopted highway as such any works are HS
having required to achieve the visit
business putting in say that visibility
space are you the trimming back of
overhanging branches thus can be carried
out so county have confirmed that you
know there was a highway there and
there's maybe there is material over
growing but once a highway always
highway though the county of said it
unless you want confirmation from the
county again to confirm this but they're
saying that the visibility sprays can be
undertaken if the hedge as it will
continues to grow in the future then
impacts on visibility split displays of
what we're putting in what this proposed
they won't let me require to cut those
back they should be yes so this does
impact the neighbor in future well in
terms of cutting back my hedges whether
it's now or in the future it will impact
I can't advise on the on the whole
aspect but I'm an on your own language
of course you can cut you back
it's dangerous but on County I believe
council brain is is correct on that but
this would be a highway so the county
should be obliged to actually cut it
back to the boundary but I can't quite
confirm Karen's gonna come back in on
this one the time Gerardus physicists
the hedgerow and he works to the
hedgerow in terms of the business
disabilities play are only in relation
to the visibility splay so we're not
appreciate that there's some concern
that this might inadvertently prejudice
the hedge the information from the
highways officer is the visibility
sprays are entirely within the adopted
highway so any growth from the hedge
would be onto the adopted highway there
would be a requirement to keep that to
keep that clear in any case so we are
talking we're not saying that only any
works have to be done to the hedge to
enable the visibility displays to be
achieved there was there achieved
entirely within the highway sorry
thank you I did ask prior to the meeting
not to interrupt we have one meeting
that the officers speak please I thought
if it if it it says the information
available to me suggests that the
visibility sprays are entirely within
the adopted highway neh removal required
for their implementation can therefore
be achieved so there is no there is no
impact in terms of the hedge other than
where it encroaches over onto adopted
highway contradictory this is in
I'm gonna suggest we defer this another
candy council officer at the site visit
chair I was going to exactly recommend
that proposal and can we have a highways
officer present we can request the
reason I ask the reason I ask that I I
would assume highways have done a
desktop appraisal rather than carry out
a site visit and if they've done a
desktop appraisal when they have a
photograph taken by the by the highways
officer of the site attached to an email
to the case officer so yes I can confirm
this was not a desktop study this was a
site visit and an assessment done from
that and I understand there was free up
discussions as well with with the
applicant
so this matter has been rehearsed twice
can I just come can I just come back on
that did the highway speak make contact
with the the neighboring the neighbors
in the neighboring property who's headed
to impacts mister I'm I'm really
concerned about this HM because my
living kinds and we had an overhanging
hedge over a path we've got the County
Council came along cut it back and then
gave the invoice to the people inside
yeah they're gone and it keeps
overhanging and I say all of a sudden
this hedge is overhanging the highway so
wine earth they weren't they asking the
owners of this house to cut it back in
you know previous
you know like counselor Perry I thought
they've done desktop job but obviously
you know but just I mean III so I went
there and yesterday and looked at a
booth visibility's plays I thought was a
big concern with that the
counter-argument could be is yeah
perhaps you know perhaps the resident is
lucky that the county council haven't
asked them to quarterback already but we
will move on Chris people and I think
we've had a proposed cancel rank come
back in please
talk at first and actually last year I
had to cut my hedge back in bird nesting
season because it was overhanging
the visibility of the junction I needed
by that much about to cut about but I
think the only way to resolve this I'm
quite clear in the south deferral for a
site visit I think we're quite clear on
this now we've had a proposal on a
second to propose the counts of Perry
and second boy Epps the cancer case of
rain proposed
uncaps the Perry second deferral of the
application for a site visit with the
request that a county council officer
attend but with the request neighboring
properties should be advised when that's
going to be carried out myself
sorry just on many dealings with the
county about highways and village greens
it's very difficult to rebut the
presumption that it is a highway so if
they insist it is our way then it's
going to be a difficult argument that we
are going to have for the county council
excuse me
one at a time takes a brain cancer
program in Kansas the counselors the
council officers can ask for an extent
map which will show the highway where it
is and where it isn't
it's the Perry venkat other side I was
just going to request for a loan
registry map of the property
so that we can actually see exactly
where the chair just to interject a
minute learn referee plans basically I
only show basically informal boundary
unless you actually are salon registry
for the boundary to be fixed and very
few properties have a fixed boundary yes
okay society if you want to come in to
say what counts the brains already told
us that you can get a highways extent
map of County highways all right now I
could do it even just had one thing
sometimes the county maps are very very
old to decipher so be wary know in my
experience they're smart new maps on a
modern GIS system with the highways
extends marked over in Brown right that
they're not like the church is perhaps
in Stratford district I think mr. Nash
is just too realized that you're right
and he's not better we've proposed on a
second that we defer this application
for site visit and request an officer
attendance from the County Council
should we go through that all those in
favor committee committee resolves to
defer application 1900 one for 9fu
owl thank you
Yeah right if we can no I think we'll
carry on come on right who said that
right next item is not final one for
tonight nineteen slash zero two seven
three not ful all passages strap the
drug trading turn 22 meter further
expense along the boundary of the
property face in a three 400 Road
standard wooden the feather a 20 meter
store with a 200 by 38 millimeter gravel
board attached to the bottom the post
wooden post attached to the concrete
godfathers the good side facing the road
the presenter is Joe thank you Joe
thank you the application site is
situated within the physical physical
confines of Trenton village as indicated
by the black dot before you this
application closes a 22 meter wooden
fence close to the eastern boundary of
all postures that fronts the a 3,400 the
boundary is currently formed by sparse
trees bushes and other vegetation the
dweller all passes is a two-story
detached dwelling and he's sighted
further towards the western apart away
from the main road the site is also
located within the tradition
Conservation Area and his engagements
are great to start listed built grade 2
listed building the Thursday as
indicated on the plan there's the old
pastures proposed
fence line and they go to grade 2 listed
building directly adjacent
the pro scheme includes a landscaping
plan which is before you the details the
plants and vegetation between the fence
and the highway the plan before you
shows the pros fencing detail are
submitted for the application this photo
shows the front of old pastures fronting
onto a three 400 so this is the fence
line you can just see old pushes their
time their shows with roughly the photos
taken this is the cross-section view of
the old pastures so it costs actually
coming in to Trenton from south into the
north old passes just their fence on
would have been down there if proved
this photo was taken just to the north
of the old parks is approximately 50
meters still fronts on ca3 400 and also
demonstrates similar examples so you can
see there was a fence on there and you
see on the map there just how far
forward it is this photos taken further
up foxing about 80 meters see another
fence line fronting on ca3 400 trying to
show reflective examples then when you
come in out to the north of tried in
turn so you're heading towards
stratford-upon-avon up here for the
Mayan Empire if you look at the AC
treads and down there to apologies so
Stratfor's coming that way there is
other fence lines it's been improved
it's still within the conservation area
and this application 2014 it was
approved in 2014 when the fence on run
along the a3 400 once again and his
quite referred to in the officers report
thanks Jeff officer recommendation is
for approval and there are no age to
come out first speaker which is Hannah
Bagwell
and I must apologize for keeping you
this long so many apologies to Liz
you've got three minutes so far away
when you're ready and if you go past the
rep I'm sure everyone wants to go home
good evening everyone and thank you for
having me here today my name is Hannah
bate crow liver old passages in
Reddington with my husband and my two
year old son we've spent the past three
years renovating our pastures and
landscaping the gardens
now we've applied for planning
permission to erect this fence along the
garden boundary that faces the busy a340
zero to reduce noise pollution improve
the privacy safety and enjoyment of our
garden for our whole family
in particular for our little boy who
would love to play in the garden but
currently has to play on our driveway
because it's safer and protected from
the road we've discussed the plans with
all of our neighbors and they've been
happy with them and haven't made any
objections I do appreciate the concerns
raised by councillor Chris st. so I'd
like to address them now
first you with regard to visibility as
you can see from the slides 1 & 2 they
use demonstrate that there's no
visibility issues turning into the a340
zero slide 3 shows the location of the
car at the junction of black railroad
and the a340 zero the fence will be
within our garden behind the existing
fence therefore it won't be visible from
the Blackwell Road junction the fence
will be setback greater than 3 meters
from the edge of the pavement this is
more than the 0.5 metres required by the
work show County Council Highway
Authority and the fo Highway Authority
has agreed
that visibility will not be affected
with regard to secondly with regard to
the concerns about the fences impact on
the setting we have worked with the
planning office offices to minimize the
impact we have moved it now into our
gardens so it will not be visible from
black railroad as you can see from slide
fall it will be well screen behind
existing planting on the a 3400 as you
can see from slides five and six there
are multiple examples of similar fences
running along the a340 serie in treading
ten thirdly with regard to vegetation
with regard to the suggestion that
effective screening could be provided by
vegetation it will take several years
for the current planting scheme to
greatest sufficient thickness to provide
a safe and effective screen for our
family and thank you very much like
several people are doing hands up I'm
sorry I didn't notice the comment that
you've been packed for the past few
years renovating our past years are you
turning it into pastures new but sorry
about that I've been trying to do that
what Oh a bird so sorry about the bonds
of I just wonder whether you can just
advise is the fence game to be just
natural wood or was it going to be
painted to sort of blend in with the
vegetation at all I'm we're open to
suggestions really in terms of the
painting I mean some of the fences in
the village are natural and some of them
I think have been painted so you know I
think we'd be happy to taste it I think
there was this example suppose wasn't
there on one taste presentation yeah
further questions no you're free to go
thank you and grab our ward member which
is Katz the site I must apologize to
catch the Saint because in the papers
he's caught catch the J st. so many
apologies for that
and I hope you accept it was just a
pervy top writer I had a spotty that
chairman I've spotted one or two you're
awful jokes tonight that right the
situation is this I seem to have been
playing ping-pong with David Cutler over
the last week a few days over a number
of issues because what I think is that
the comparison we fences further down
the road that the joke odd upper and
Hannah's just referred to are totally
irrelevant to this particular
application and I'm being very serious
with you tonight very serious indeed
because the problem is visibility now
accounts the Perry asks a question about
visibility and was shown slides
well I've got a slightly bigger car than
the one that was shown in the pictures
but he's not that big and I know I have
particular difficulty in seeing up the
a3 400 if I try and drive out of
Blackwell Road and effectively quite a
number of other people that I represent
feel that way now we have a situation
whereby in the past week I've had copy
of a letter from WCC development group
which you often call County highways and
effectively
so I just thought I'd just pause a
minute then I've had a copy of
development group which says the
position of the fence and age is
overlapping with adoptee high wave and
then I had a note from David Kutner that
said oh they've moved it back here's a
diagram saying they've moved it back by
a couple of metres well it would have
been fine if he had actually given me a
drawing with a fence being moved back a
couple of metres also I think handle was
slightly wrong tonight about the coyote
highways because they did states in
their letter that this edge must be kept
trimmed to maintain the visibility so we
have a situation whereby there's very
confusing information on this particular
thing I'm quite happy for Hanna to have
her hedge in the right place but I think
I've got a duty as the local
representative and local councillor to
make certain that people can look up the
road safely when they try and drive out
of that junction at the moment they
cannot you just cannot see up that road
it's it's impossible and that you kind
of take your life in your hands and did
there and everything and then you have
to watch what's happening the other
direction as well and it's not a
particularly safe Junction right I can
see councillor Perry nodding her head
she loves to disagree with me on on on
highways issues and safety issues pistou
and parking issues but effectively I'm
being as serious as I could ever be this
is a problem what do we need is to
withdraw my objection here's a diagram a
proper drawing which shows the edge and
the fence in the position as proposed it
doesn't exist at the present time we
haven't seen it tonight and the version
that mr.
gartner sent to me was effectively it's
there look it's right on the boundary is
not back and effectively it needs to be
back and therefore I think if it was put
back a couple of metres and the drawing
was was redrawn at that level we could
approve it but I think based on the
diagrams and the drawings that we've got
at the moment it is somewhat difficult
to approve
hey can I just ask very quick question
the middle is the fence is supposed to
be in front of the hedge I'm trying to
find out where it is so how does the
hedge relevant poem I don't understand
his ability Danny I'm gonna show you
about a fence not a hedge slightly
confused Chris the application we got
before us isn't for the fence not the
hedgerow head rose a separate entity
with anything from the course
[Music]
obstruction it's a hedge which is not
part of the application before is his
offence with respect when I was told
about it as local Waldman but the
application was for the fence
plus the planting scheme and he even had
comments from Ruth Rose about it in the
planning file I'm just looking at what
it says it says 22 metres of feather
edge fencing board which is not the head
right but it's still mine right on the
highway and he's not set back
if the officer saw the committee or
whoever tell me that there will be under
this revised scheme if you prove it
you've got sufficient visibility then I
will withdraw my objection now but I
don't have the evidence to do that now
right at the present time it just
doesn't exist and it's no good trying to
camouflage that cancel bonds motive
comment really as far as I can see the
problem is the edge not the application
that we've got for the prints inside for
security I could see where Chris is
coming from the hedge what's that who
does reduce the visibility if it becomes
a problem
what is your candy council would be
involved they were so the notice on the
London to have it job done all right
it doesn't work like that Mike at the
moment what we have to do is get the
Parish Council to try and deal with it
with the landowner for County Council
run a mile no points of clarification
I've got one point of clarification is
that's the existent thank you gets the
st. but one point of clarification
before we go on where the Toyota is that
hedge would the fence be behind that
hedge it's a silly question but I just
want to make sure that there will not
got any other points of contracts that
question I was going to ask mr. chair
that's the brain I can see exactly where
cancer Saints coming from in relation to
that I've made that known already what
would happen with the edge but I think
the applicant deserved what I've said as
well and she's not in her head I have no
problem with the fence because it's set
back Pedro is a separate entity I will
support and propose that we go to the
officers recommendation for approval the
Barnes
thanks for sure yeah when I first saw I
mean I drove it Blackwell road is it
yeah yeah I drove down yesterday now
going I thought off I don't like the
look of a offense there I have freedom
but then I found that it was going to be
behind the hedgerow and then seeing the
other fences up from there for three
three four hundred I can't see any
objections to it feels so I will go with
the obvious recommendation as long so we
go to the vote is that the best thing
I've said or not good bharden right both
those in favor of agreeing with the
officers recommendation to approve this
application please indicate committee
results grant application 18 star zero
two seven three nine ful
and there's no urgent business
Sarkar meeting